This is Jocko podcast number
35 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
Weeper was ahead when he and born reached
the gap in the wire star shale after
star shell was going up now and
the whole line did woken up.
Machine guns were talking,
but there was one that would not talk.
The rattle of musketry continued,
but the mist was kindly to them.
It had thickened again
as they got beyond the trampling
clutching wire born saw weeper a couple of
paces ahead of him and what he thought
was the last of their party disappearing
into the missed about 20 yards away.
He was glad to be clear of the wire.
Another star's Gel went up and they
both froze stillness under it's glare.
Then they moved again.
Hurrying for all they were worth born.
Felt a sense of triumph and
escape thrill in him. Anyway,
the Hun couldn't see him.
Now
something kicked him in the
upper part of the chest.
Rending its way through him and his
agonized cry was scarcely on a bull in the
rush of blood from his mouth
as he collapsed and fell.
We per turned his head over his shoulder,
listened, stopped and went back.
He found born trying to lift
himself and born spoke, gasping,
suffocating. Go on. I'm scuppered,
I'll not leave the said Wipper said
weeper he stood and lifted the other in is
huge on Ganglia arms.
Carrying him as tenderly as
though we were a child born.
Struggled weirdly to speak in the blood,
feeling his mouth prevented him.
Sometimes his head fell on weeper
shoulder that last barely articulate.
A few words came.
I'm finished.
Leamy and peace for God's sake.
You can't,
I'll not leave the said
weeper in infuriate rage,
he felt born stretch himself in
a convulsive shutter and relax,
becoming suddenly heavier in his arms.
He struggled on stumbling over the shell
plowed ground through that fantastic
mist, which moved like an army of
wraiths hurrying away from him.
Then he stopped and taking the body
by the waist with his left arm,
flung it over his shoulder,
steadying it with his right.
He could see their wire now and
presently he was challenged and replied.
He found the way through the wire
and staggered into the
trench with his burden.
And he turned down the short stretch.
Yeah,
to monk trench trench and came
on the rest of the party outside.
A company's dug out.
I brought him back.
He cried desperately and collapsed
with the body on the duck boards
in that is from a book called
the middle parts of fortune,
which is written by a gay
guy named Frederick Manning
who served with the Kings
Shropshire light infantry
in world war one.
He served with the seventh battalion at
the battle of the Somme and after the
war he became a writer in the book,
which is actually a novel,
but based on his experiences was published
as being written by private one nine
zero two two total got
originally published and then
after his death he finally
received credit for writing it
and it's a,
it's a very powerful book and I wanted
to start with that excerpt from World War
One because it is the most shining in
my mind in most horrific example of
attrition warfare,
almost 20 million killed usually over a
few hundred yards of trench and I can't,
I can't stand that.
Attrition warfare is a strategy in which
one side tries to grind down and wear
down the other side
and they break when they
no longer have the men,
the soldiers,
the people,
the humans or the
supplies to keep it going
and it's brutal and it also gives no real
advantage to intellect thought and to
tactical prowess on the battlefield
and I don't like it.
Now the opposite of attrition
warfare is maneuver warfare.
And that's what we're
going to dive into tonight.
The book is the Maneuver Warfare Handbook,
but as we talk about it,
think about it not just being
about war and about combat,
but about how attrition,
warfare and maneuver warfare can be
easily seen in the way that we lead in.
No, and also in the way we interact
with other people with other humans,
which is what leading is.
Hmm.
And so here we go into
this book right here,
maneuver warfare handbook.
It's written by William s Linde
and we'll get into him in a minute.
Here we go.
With the book.
I served over 31 years active
duty with the marine corps,
saw combat in both Korea and Vietnam and
attended service schools from the basic
school to the National War College.
Yet only toward the end of my military
career did I realize how little I really
understood the art of war.
Even as a PFC in Korea after
being medivaced along with
most of my platoon after
a fruitless frontal assault against
superior North Korean forces,
it seemed to me there had to
be a better way to wage war.
17 years later commanding a bat,
a battalion at k song,
I was resolved that none of my re marines
would die for lack of superior combat
power,
but we were still relying
on the concentration of
superior fire power to win,
essentially still practicing grants,
attrition warfare and we were
still doing frontal assaults.
That opening right there
is a colonel John c stuck,
uh, Marine Corps obviously, and
he just kinda explained his, his,
his career path serving in both Korea
and Vietnam and he goes on the author of
this book, so he's doing the foreword
to this book, Maneuver Warfare.
The author of this book has never served
a day of active military duty and he
has never been shot at,
although there are no doubt some senior
officers would like to remedy that later
ladder deficiency.
So he's a little bit unpopular.
The guy that wrote this book
with some with some people,
yet he demonstrates an
amazing understanding of the
art of war as have only a
small handful of military thinkers
I have come across in my career.
So he's talking about this
Guy William William s Lind.
Okay.
And here he goes into some details
on William s Lind and how he,
how he came into contact with them.
Back to the book.
When I first heard bill Lind speak,
I must confess,
I resented a mirror civilian expressing
criticism of the way our beloved core
did things. After all,
he was not one of us.
He had not shed blood with us in battle.
He was not a brother and I had strong
suspicions that he would have difficulty
passing the Pft, meaning the
physical test of physical this.
So this guy with a Linde,
not,
not exactly a high level athlete,
but what he said made sense for the first
time I was personally hearing someone
advocate a new unapproached,
a war that was based on intellectual
innovation rather than sheer material
superiority, mission type
orders, surfaces and gaps.
She feared punked instead of the rigid
formulas and checklists that we normally
associate with our training and doctrine.
It was a stimulating experience
through Lynn's articulation.
Years of my own reading of military
history began to make a lot more sense.
Okay,
but why all this from a civilian instead
of a professional soldier? In fact,
the entire movement for,
for military reform is driven
largely by civilian intellectuals,
not military officers. One notable
exception being retired air force,
Colonel John Boyd.
When you think about it,
this is not surprising.
We have never institutionalized a system
that encourages innovative ideas or
curry or criticism from subordinates.
So there you go.
It's the military w
what do you say to your,
what do you say to your superior officer?
I don't think that's a good plan. No.
What they're told to
do is support the plant
proposing significant change.
His view,
frequently viewed as
criticism of superiors.
Since they are responsible for the way
things are and borders on disloyalty,
if not insubordination.
So it is not surprising that the Movement
for reform comes from outside the
military establishment.
And he goes on to say Bh Lid,
that Ladelle heart,
which Bh Liddell Hart was a guy
that fought in world war one,
a Brit that fought in world
war one battle the psalm,
he got hit three times,
uh,
eventually was gassed set out on the
line and almost his entire battalion was
wiped out.
And this guy eventually
wrote a book called strategy,
an indirect approach.
And an interesting,
I pulled up one quote from him,
um,
often the longest way around
is the shortest way there.
This is the indirect approach.
So anyways,
back to the book here on what
Bh Ladelle heart said bl, uh,
heart once remark that the only thing
harder than getting a new idea into the
military mind is to get an old one out
in 1925 when he was expounding such
hysterical theories as
the indirect approach,
the American General Service Schools
Review of current military literature
dismissed one of Lidl hearts major works
as negative value to the instructors at
these schools.
I expect Marine Corps schools to
receive this publication with similar
enthusiasm,
but I cannot believe a professional
military officer would not benefit reading
it.
Okay,
so that's if you took to,
to catch the setup of this
book. He's saying, look,
this is different than what we've been
taught. This is the different in in,
by the way, this, this book, I'm
checking the dates right now.
This came out in 1985 so there has been
progress in this direction since then.
But at the time that this came out,
it was just,
it was viewed as almost
insubordination to think this way.
So let's jump into it right here
with the theory of maneuver warfare.
So now we're getting to Linde himself.
Writing maneuver warfare is not new.
It probably dates from the
first time a caveman surprise,
an enemy from behind instead
of meeting him club to club.
Sometimes the word maneuver is
used as a synonym for movement.
Such such as in references to fire
and maneuver in small unit tactics.
So that's, you know, we have in the
book extreme ownership cover move and,
and that's what we're talking about.
We're talking about move,
he's saying fire maneuver is the same
use of the word maneuver to mean move.
Yeah.
Maneuver is organized movement of
troops during combat operations to a new
access and region for
the purpose of taking an
advantageous position relative to
the enemy in order to deliver a decisive
strike so that that's sort of the
classical definition,
but when used in the phrase maneuver
warfare maneuver means much more.
Only recently has someone suggested a
convincing answer of of what maneuver
means.
That man is a retired air force colonel
and fighter pilot named John Boyd.
Colonel Boyd's development of the theory
of maneuver warfare began not with
ground battles,
but with a study of some mock air to
air combat exercises conducted at Nellis
Air Force Base in 1974 that led him
back to the study of air to air combat.
During the Korean War.
American aviators were very
successful in that conflict.
They achieved a 10 to one
kill ratio over there.
North Korean and Chinese opponents.
Colonel Boyd began his
study with a question,
how and why did we do so well?
He noted in several tradition,
he noted that in several traditional
measures of aircraft performance,
the principal communist fighter,
the make 15 was superior to the
American f 86 so you might think,
oh, Americans always have the
best technology, not true. So and,
and Boyd will end up doing void.
We're going to hear quite
a bit about them right now,
but this guy was sort of a strategic
genius in the air force and a bunch of
people on Twitter hit me and social media.
I've always been saying,
you gotta do Boyd,
got to do Boyd and I,
and I know I've got to
do Boyd at some point.
And this is sort of a good
introduction to Boyd. So here's the,
here's the difference between the make
15 and the American f 86 the mic 15 it
could climb and accelerate faster and
it had better sustained turn rate.
But in two less obvious measures
of aircraft performance,
the [inaudible] 86 was much
superior to the mic. First.
The pilot could see out much bet better.
The fat six bubble canopy gave its
pilot very good outward vision.
While the Migs faired fared,
canopy made it difficult to see out.
Second,
the SF 86 had a high powered and highly
effective hydraulic controls and the meg
did not.
This meant that while the Mig could do
many individual actions including turn,
climb and accelerate
better than the fat six,
the fat six could transition from one
action to another much more quickly than
the Mig.
It was better in the transition,
so for all you Jujitsu players
and you start that scramble,
you start that scrambled,
the the f 86 is a better scrambler.
Using these two superiorities,
the American pilots developed a tactical
approach that forced the Mig into a
series of actions each.
Each time the action changed.
The fad six gained a time advantage
because the f 86 pilot could see more
quickly how the situation had changed
and he could also make his aircraft shift
more quickly to a new action so he
can see what's happening faster.
Then once he sees it, which he saw faster,
now he can make his adjustment faster.
With each change,
the migs actions became more inappropriate
until they were so inappropriate that
the Mig gave the fat six
a good firing opportunity.
Often it appeared the Mig pilot realized
what was happening to him and panicked
which made the American
pilot's job all the easier.
Okay.
Later,
Colonel Boyd began studying ground combat
to see if there were any situations
similar to that he had found
in the air war over Korea.
He found that in battles campaigns
in wars like Vicksburg and France,
a similar things seem to have happened
one side at presented the other with a
sudden unexpected change or a series
of such changes to which it could not
adjust in a timely manner.
As a result,
it was defeated and it was generally
defeated at small costs as the victor.
Often the losing side had been
physically stronger than the winner,
just like the Mig 15 was,
was physically faster, it,
it didn't matter
and often the same sort of panic and
paralysis the North Korean and Chinese
pilots had shown seem to occur.
Colonel Boyd asked himself,
what did all these cases have in common?
His answer was what is now
called the Boyd theory,
which is the theory of maneuver warfare.
The briefing Colonel Boyd gives to explain
his theory patterns of conflict takes
over five hours. So he, so the,
so Colonel Boyd does give this brief and
it takes over five hours or he did when
he was,
when he was alive,
but at the cost of missing some of the
subtleties and supporting historical
evidence in the briefing,
it can be summarized as follows.
So here's a kind of a synopsis
of the Boyd Theory that, uh,
Lind is going to put
together for us right now.
Okay.
Back to the book.
Conflict can be seen as time
competitive observation,
orientation,
decision action cycles.
Each party to a conflict begins
by observing. He observes himself,
has physical surroundings and his
enemy on the basis of his opposite
observation,
he orients.
That is to say he makes a mental image
or snapshot of his situation on the basis
of this orientation. He makes a decision,
he puts the decision into effect.
I,
he,
he acts then because he assumes his
action has changed the situation.
He observes again and
starts the process of new.
His actions follow a cycle,
sometimes called the Boyd cycle or
Ooda loop and Buddhas o d a and that's
observe, Orient, decide and act.
If one side in a conflict can consistently
go through the Boyd cycle faster than
the other, it gains a
tremendous advantage, advantage.
By the time the slower side acts,
the faster side is doing something
different from what he observed and his
action is inappropriate.
With each cycle.
The slower parties action
is inappropriately,
is inappropriate by a larger time margin,
even though he desperately strives
to do something that will work,
each action is less useful
than its predecessor.
He falls further and further behind.
Ultimately,
he ceases to be effective
and neat. We clearly, I mean,
this is obvious and combat is also obvious
and in Jiu Jitsu, I mean very clear.
When you're training,
when you're rolling with somebody,
if they're not making adjustments
fast enough, you just,
it's two or three,
two or three transitions and you got them,
you're on their back.
You,
yeah.
The Boyd theory defines what
is meant by the word maneuver.
In the term maneuver warfare
maneuver means Boyd cycling,
Boyd cycling the enemy being consistently
faster through however many Ooda loops
it takes until the enemy
loses his cohesion,
until he can no longer fight and
as an effective organized force,
sometimes a Boyd cycled enemy
panics or becomes passive.
This is an ideal outcome for the victor
because a panicked passive enemy can be
annihilated, captured at the
lowest cost in friendly casualties.
At other times,
the outmaneuvered enemy may continue
to fight as individuals or small units,
but because he can no longer
act effectively as a force,
he is comparatively easy to destroy.
Okay,
so continuing on,
if the object in maneuver warfare is to
move through the Ooda loops faster than
the enemy, what do you need to do?
How can you be consistently faster?
Much of the much of the rest of this book
is an effort to address that question,
but in terms of general theory, the
following points are worth thinking about.
One only a decentralized military
can have a faster Ooda loop.
If the observations must be passed up, the
chain of command, the orientation made,
and the decision taken at a high
level and the command for action then
transmitted back down the chain,
the Ooda loop is going to be slow.
As the Israeli military historian Martin
Van Creveld has observed from Plato to
NATO,
the history of command in war consists
of an endless quest for certainty.
Yeah.
Certainty concerning the state and
intention of the enemy's forces.
Certainty concerning the manifold
factors which together constitute the
environment from the weather and the
terrain to the radioactivity and presence
of chemical warfare agents.
And last but definitely not
least certainty concerning
the state and activities
of one's own forces.
Historical commanders have always faced
with a choice between two basic ways of
coping with uncertainty.
One was to construct an army of automatons
following the orders of a single man
allowed to do only that
which could be controlled.
That's centralized command.
The other two design organizations and
operations in such a way as to enable the
former to carry out the latter without
the need for continuous control this
second, the second of these methods
has that's decentralized command.
The second of these methods has by and
large proved more successful than the
first and the ongoing revolution
in the technology of command,
not withstanding,
this is likely to remain so in the
future and indeed so long as war itself
exists.
Very obvious stuff in and again,
you know in in,
in our book extreme ownership.
That's one of the principles of,
of combat decentralized
command and this is what it is.
If you don't have decentralized command
that you have to report up the chain of
command, that takes time. By the time
it gets back down what the decision,
the decision gets made at the higher
level, then they pass it back down to you.
By the time it gets to you,
it's already changed.
And that's in a Jujitsu
and Jujitsu comparison,
if you will, if you have to think about
your moves so you have instinct moves,
muscle memory. When somebody starts to
pass your guard, you get the under rock.
If you have to think about getting the
underhook and you have to command your
body to get the underwear because they
already got the under hook on you. Yeah,
so it's the same thing here.
This is that's decentralized command.
Back to the book number two,
maneuver warfare means you will not
only except confusion and disorder and
operate successfully within
it through decentralization,
you will also generate confusion
and disorder. I love that.
That's just awesome, right?
It's not just saying, hey, look,
things are getting confusing, but I'm
actually gonna create the confusion.
I'm going to make it happen.
That's something any when you see the
really good you did, you guys have been,
Glover does that. Glover creates
confusion. He creates ma'am,
he creates chaos in the gay, in the, in
the match. He wants to scramble to happen.
He wants to go as long as possible.
Okay.
The reconnaissance pole tactics
of the German blitzkrieg,
we're inherently disorderly.
Now,
is this something that's very
contrary to what people think of,
of the German military and
even the German culture?
German culture is very
orderly and here we say they,
the blitzkrieg was inherently disorderly.
Back to book higher headquarters could
neither direct nor predict the exact path
of the advance,
but the multitude of German reconnaissance
thrust generated massive confusion
among the French in 1940 each
was reported as a new attack.
The Germans seem to be everywhere and
the French who system demanded certainty
before making any decisions,
we're paralyzed.
Okay?
It's,
it's very interesting to think about that
idea of we all want to have certainty
in what's going to happen and
how in in battle and in life,
if you wait until you're 100% certain,
you're probably going to be too late.
Mm hmm.
Speaking of certainty,
three all patterns,
recipes and formulas are to be avoided.
The enemy must not be able
to predict your actions.
If you're tactics follow
predictable patterns,
the enemy can easily cut
inside your Ooda loop.
If he can predict what you will do,
he will be waiting for you.
This is why it's so hard to tell
someone how to do maneuver warfare.
There is no formula you can learn.
When someone says,
cut all the bull about theory,
just tell me what to do. You can't.
You can talk about how to think
and about some useful techniques,
but you can't give new formulas to replace
the ones currently taught instead of
a checklist or a cookbook.
Maneuver warfare requires commanders
who can sense more than they can see,
who understand the opponent's strengths
and weaknesses and their own and who can
find the enemy's critical
weaknesses in a specific situation.
They must be able to create multiple
threats and keep the enemy uncertain as to
which one is real.
They must be able to see their options
in the situation before them constantly
create new options and shift rapidly
among options as the situation develops.
General Herman Bulk,
one of the most successful
practitioners of maneuver warfare said,
I'm against the school approach that
says in accordance with the ideas of the
general staff in this situation,
you must do thus and such.
On the contrary,
you must proceed as dictated by the
personalities involved and the particulars
of the situation.
So he got a German successful German
general and he's actually saying you react
based not just on the situation of the,
of the on the ground,
put on the personalities involved.
Leadership is an art,
my friend.
Therefore one of the first principles
has to be there can be no fixed schemes.
Every scheme,
every pattern is wrong.
No two situations are identical.
That is why the study of military
history can be extremely dangerous.
Another principle that follows from is
from this is never do the same thing
twice.
Even if something works well for you,
once by the second time the
enemy will have adapted.
So you have to think of something new.
No one thinks of becoming a great
painter simply by imitating Michelangelo.
Similarly,
you can't become a great military
leader just by imitating someone.
It has to come from within.
In the last analysis,
military command is an art.
One man can do it in most will never learn
little bit of maneuver warfare and so,
so at the,
the way the book is broken up,
this book is called Maneuver
Warfare Handbook. It's,
it goes into a,
it breaks into a nother section which
we're going to get to in a minute,
but he kind of goes into a little bit.
Linde go now goes into a little bit
talking about education and training.
Okay.
Back to the book.
It is my great and this is a quote is
my great inconstant hope that the Marine
Corps will produce some
outstanding man for this country.
Such men are somewhere and they may as
well be in our classes is anywhere else.
I do not want such a person to be
hammered down by narrowness and
to have his mind cramped
by compulsory details.
It is my constant ambition to see the
marine officers filled with ambition and
initiative and originality and they can
get these attributes only by liberal
liberality of thought.
Broad thought that differs,
fought that differs from precedent
and the compulsory imprint of others.
And that is a long paragraph
that says free your mind,
free your mind. And I love pointing
us out cause this is the marine corps.
That's that. That quote is from the
commandant of the Marine Corps schools,
Brigadier General JC Breckenridge
written in 1934 in 1934 he was saying,
people, Marine Corps officers
don't go by the book,
don't obey what other people said
he wants them filled with ambition.
That's pretty normal,
but initiative and
originality he's telling to,
in order to be a good leader,
you got to free your mind.
Now, like I said, the book makes
a transition from being the,
the uh,
from being the introduction by,
by William Lind about maneuver warfare.
And then it slides into another section,
which is just about as big in this.
This part is called
fundamentals of tactics.
And this section is written
by Colonel Michael D. Wiley,
United States Marine Corps.
And he ran a course,
a of fundamentals of tactics course.
And this is sort of the,
this is the,
this is the notes from the course
when he would teach this course,
the fundamentals of tactics and a
Colonel Wiley, kind of interesting.
He went to the, went to the,
he was an enlisted marine,
then he went to the Naval Academy and
he was Jim Webb's company commander in
Vietnam, Vietnam. And,
and Jim Webb is a fairly famous guy.
He was a navy cross winner.
He's a now a CEO.
He was a senator from Virginia.
Um,
he wrote a book called fields of fire.
And then there's another great
book called the Nightingale Song,
which is,
it follows a couple,
five or so. Yeah, I
think it's, it's a web,
McCain,
Oliver North Macfarlane I think.
And, and John Poindexter. Anyways,
very prominent graduates from the naval
academy that all kind of stood out and
were, were connected throughout the
book. So this guy, so Jim Webb is,
this is this kind of a famous
guy and guy that wrote this was,
was Jim Webb's company
commander in Vietnam. So that's
kind of, it's a small world
and things tied together.
So now we get into these
lectures that he wrote in.
I don't mean to lecture anybody, but hey,
they're called lectures in this book.
I would just call them free fro
information. We're going to learn from it.
The first, the first section
is called surfaces and gaps.
The concept of surfaces and gaps is
one of several concepts that bear on
tactics.
It is unimportant whether you refer to
this concept as surfaces and gaps or soft
spot tactics or simply the idea of
pitting your strength against the enemy's
weaknesses.
That is what is all about strength
against weakness, call it what you will.
The term surfaces and gaps is derived
from a German term flaking Lucan tactic,
which means simply the
tactics of surfaces and gaps,
the surfaces being the enemy's
strong points which we avoid.
The gaps being the weak points
that we want to go through.
Now, Ladelle heart or we
talked about already today
called it the expanding
torrent system tactic.
He drew an analogy between attacking and
attacking army in a torrent of water.
If we watch our torrent bearing down on
each successive Bank of earth and dam
and its path,
we see that it first beats against the
obstacle feeling and testing it on all
points.
Eventually it fall.
It finds a small crack through this crack
pour the first droplets of water and
rush straight on. The pent up water on
each side is drawn towards the breach.
It's swirls through around the flanks
of the breach wearing away the earth on
each side and so widening
the gap simultaneously.
The water behind poor street
through that breach between this,
the side Eddie's which are wearing away
the flanks, direct lead is pass through.
It expands to widen once more the
on reach of the turn of the torrent.
Thus as the water pours through an
in and an ever increasing volume,
the on reach of the torrent swells to
its original proportion, leaving in turn,
each crumbling obstacle behind it.
Yeah,
long paragraph,
but that's how water gets through.
Things finds the weak point in piles on
the idea of putting surfaces and gaps.
Tactics into practice was
first implemented by the
German army in World War One.
This is stuff that every everybody
should know, especially military people.
In 1918 as they prepared for
Luton Dorf spring offensive,
the German army changed
its offensive tactics.
The Germans had found that they were being
overpowered by the material available
to the British and the French.
The Americans were coming and it was clear
that Germany was going to lose if she
did not do something differently
because they did not have the option of
matching the allies strength and material,
the German society that they
would have to out think them.
That is they would have
to have better tactics.
Germany did not succeed in winning the
war. It was too late. By this time.
They were surrounded, but women
and children were starving at home.
It was simply too late for them to win.
Yet they made some tactical
progress there. At the last,
at last in the spring of
1918 they inflicted terrible
defeats on their enemies
to the point that the allied armies were
seriously considering the prospect of
giving up at the tactical level.
The Germans put their strength against
weakness. They sought the gaps.
Small assault groups called sturm grouping
sought gaps in the enemy lines and
attack through them assaulting
with light machine guns, rifles,
grenades and flame throwers.
While heavy machine guns
direct and indirect weapons,
including trench mortars were used
to suppress enemy's strong points,
but on the strategic level,
the spring of 1918 off offensive failed.
Why?
Because Luton Dorf on that level
puts strength against strength.
He was seek though he was seeking gaps.
He was seeking gaps at
the enemy's strong points.
That's a very great, great
information to have. So yeah,
the guys on the ground war attacking the
weak points, but the strategic picture,
they were still attacking a strong area,
so you might've found a little weakness
in a wall, a little weakness in the wire,
a little weakness in the trench,
but they were attacking a,
let's say a 20 mile trench that
was overall was a strong area,
whereas they should have looked for where
the flanks are a hundred miles away.
Back to the book,
the idea of putting strength
against weakness was of
course born way before 1918
Klaus fits writes about it in chapter
nine and 10 of book seven in chapter nine
regarding defensive positions.
He states the attack cannot
prevail against them.
It has no means at its disposal to
counteract their advantage in practice.
Not all defensive positions are like this.
If the attacker sees that he can
get away without assaulting them,
it would be stupid of
him not to attempt it.
There'll be stupid of him to attempt it.
It is a risky business to attack
an abl opponent in a good position.
Same thing we heard from Sun Tzu.
You don't attack heavily
defended positions.
Okay.
Back to the book.
Employment of this concept of surfaces
and gaps then gives us many advantages
over what could be called
slower moving forms of combat,
where strength is thrown against strength.
Attacking through gaps.
Surfaces
gives us an advantage of economy of force.
If we are pitted.
Strength against strength,
assaulting enemy's strong points.
We are consuming our manpower as well as
ammunition to supplies as we go along.
If we go through the gaps,
we are practicing economy of force.
We are reaching our objective
without using up our men.
We are leaving the enemy behind
because we are moving faster.
We have the advantage
of rapid exploitation,
so when you tack obviously tack weaknesses
you lose less. Be Lose less men.
Now this is important.
The concept of surfaces and gaps demands
leadership from the front as opposed to
leadership from the rear.
The commander must be where
he can make swift decisions.
He must be where the
situation is developing.
Obviously leadership from the front
had become a scarcity in world war one.
JFC follower in his book,
General Ship wrote in the World War.
Nothing was more dreadful to witness
that a chain of men starting with a
battalion commander and ending with
the army commander sitting in telephone
boxes improvised or actual talking,
talking,
talking in place of
leading, leading, leading.
The result was unresponsive
leadership and slow reactions.
We actually talked about this on the
last podcast when Leif was talking about
being in an assault force and being in
the assault train, which is 20 guys,
15 or 20 guys and he was standing always
at the end of the train cause that's
where he was told he
was supposed to be in.
He didn't know what's going on
the front so he couldn't help.
He couldn't make any decisions.
If someone was going to,
if he needed to make a decision,
well we couldn't even make a decision
because you know what's going on up there.
But if someone said, hey, we
need a decision from the boss,
they had to pass that
word all the way back,
not good,
so you got to lead from the front with
decentralized command and be far enough
the phone. I don't want to make it
sound that simple. You've got to be,
it's the same thing we talked about,
like if you've got to be far enough
forward that you can understand what's
happening up there and obviously you,
but you don't want to be the guy that's
doing the shooting cause then you've
gone too far forward to actually
be detached and make decisions.
Certainly combat is not
going to be that simple.
The gap then might be any undefended
point or any weekly defended point.
It may be any enemy vulnerability.
It might be the enemies of flanks.
The term flank itself
needs some elaboration.
Think of it as a relative thing.
John Boyd defines a flank as
that aspect of that aspect.
Toward which a force is not
devoting its primary attention.
In other words and fluid warfare,
what is one moment the enemy's flank might
the next moment be the enemy's front?
It depends on how he is
directing his attention.
A gap for the infantry could
be an enemy missile site,
manned by troops or not combat oriented.
The missile site might be a surface
if you are flying on an airplane,
but a gap if you were a light infantry
men who has gotten inside and me lines.
So,
okay,
does that make sense to you?
So if you've got,
if you've got a surface to air missile,
okay,
launcher and it,
it has a radar radar on it and
it can track aircraft coming in.
And if you're a a fighter aircraft,
you don't want to say what do you want
to stay away from that thing because
it'll get you locked on railroad is
going to fire a heat seeking missile that
you and kill you. So for them it's
a surface. It's a strong point.
For an aircraft it's a strong point.
But for a ground troop, they don't put,
you know,
the highest level troops guarding these
things cause they're in the rear a
little bit. They put like kind of, you
know, some what they call them here. Uh,
they're manned by troops
who are not combat oriented.
So that means it's a softer target.
Yeah.
Back to the book. Let us say we are
unsuccessful in finding any gaps.
Yeah,
we may have to create gaps and
there are ways of doing this.
So then they talk about the ways you can
do it. You can do it through fire power,
but dropping bombs by suppression,
by assault,
all those different ways to
create gaps with, with, you know,
using direct fire to soften up targets.
And then I like these
tactics a little bit better.
Another way of creating gaps
is through supporting attacks.
By attacking one point along the line,
we may divert the enemy from another point
and by drawing them off, create a gap.
Again, this isn't linear terms for
instructional purposes, for simplicity,
but do not get a linear mindset.
Sometimes a less costly way of creating
a gap is through deception by causing
the enemy to think that we will attack
at one point there by enticing him to
draw his forces off from another point.
And when he attack that point
where he has weakened herself.
But what do we do about
surfaces that his strong points,
sometimes they are best bypassed
once the enemy has been bypassed,
his strong point may be cutoff from its
support and in that way his strong point
eventually withers away and becomes a
weak point, which we can attack later.
Okay.
You know,
we talk a lot in here about not
attacking people's defensible positions.
And this is just a classic, another
way of saying that, you know, some we,
we talk about people with got the ego,
the big ego and how you don't
want to confront that ego. Well,
if you can bypass the ego, eventually
the ego doesn't become a factor anymore.
And that's the same thing when
you're doing ground combat.
Back to the book.
There are certain problems presented
by the concept of surfaces and gaps,
especially to commanders who are
to slow moving forms of combat.
One is that the commander will not
always know where all his people are.
In the Marine Corps.
We become used to being accountable at
all times for knowing exactly where every
man is in this faster moving form of
combat to do so would be impossible.
Your subordinates or finding the gaps and
exploiting them. So you've got you've,
you're a control freak.
You're not going to be able to pull this
off cause I'm saying well where are you
echo, where are you echo where are you
know, echoes out there. He's working,
he's finding some gaps to get through,
not know exactly where he is.
Another problem is that
artillery in air might not be,
may not be controlled as closely as is
possible and slowing slower moving forms
of combat. So you start to deal with
the problems of, of air support.
And artillery is a little trickier to
use because you have people moving around
the battlefield and you're not sure
where everyone is and that makes it very
difficult because you obviously don't
want to drop bombs on your own people.
Another problem associated with the
concept of surfaces and gaps is that as we
penetrate deeply,
often on narrow fronts,
our flanks become exposed.
There are however compensating factors,
again related to speed,
we are moving quickly.
The enemy is always off balance.
Remember the old adage
there is security in speed,
so in other words, as you
penetrate into a, into a zone,
you're going to be exposed a little bit,
but if you're moving fast,
you can deal with that exposure.
Critics of these faster moving forms of
combat characterized by initiative at
the low level fear that
they will lead groups,
two groups of men moving willy nilly
about the battlefield and that commanders
will lose control. So people say,
Oh, you know, if I give so much,
so much initiative at the low level,
if I'm going to lose control of it,
then people are going to be running
around like chickens with their heads cut
off this need not be.
So if the concept of surfaces
and gaps is employed properly,
it will not be. So that is why we
have control measures the boundary,
the limit of advanced the
phase line can still be used.
It must be remembered that these control
measures should serve their function
but not be rigid lines that
cannot be changed or ignored.
When the situation changes,
they should be kept to a minimum
and must always be flexible.
The tactics must never follow the
control measures. On the contrary,
the control measures must follow the
tactics and the tactics must always be
based on the enemy.
Other concepts that will be
discussed in the chapters ahead,
especially that of the main
effort gives us meaning,
gives us means of keeping control over
our troops and preventing a situation
where they can be said to be moving
willy nilly about the battlefield.
So decentralized command it.
It is challenging and if you don't
do it right, you will have chaos.
So now we get into the next section and
it does say lecture again, but again,
I'm not here to lecture anybody.
I don't think I,
I don't think I can pull that off.
The concept,
this one,
this section is called mission tactics.
The concept of mission
tactics like surfaces and gaps
must always be at work in
battle.
The name is the name is derived
from the German Alf trags tactic,
which means literally mission tactics.
It is no accident that the
name includes the word tactics.
Assigning a mission and depending on
subordinates to carry it out constitutes
the tactic to allow the subordinate to
decide on his own initiative what to do
is the means of getting the most
appropriate decisions made on the spot and
acted on more rapidly than the
enemy can respond to your actions.
Got to get your subordinate leadership
to lead. You want them to lead.
This is the account of
Prince Frederick Charles,
who is giving a tongue lashing to one
of his majors for committing a tactical
blunder in defense of his action.
The major explained that he was only
following orders in the Prussian army.
The major reminded the prints and order
from a senior officer was tantamount to
an order from the king.
The prince was unimpressed.
His reply to the major was the king made
you a major because he thought you were
smart enough to know
when not to obey orders.
Then that is the essence
of mission tactics.
The subordinate decides what to do
even if even if it means that the order
issued by his senior now
should be changed or adjusted.
The mission assigned is sacred.
The mission is the output that the
commander wants. That does not change,
but how that output is to be achieved may
change and it is up to the intelligent
subordinate to decide
whether or not it has
total freedom for the
subordinate leadership to
figure out how they want to make
this happen. They know what
they need to get done, but they,
they have the freedom to figure out
how they're going to make it happen.
Back to the book,
there is a classic example.
Use Time and time again and introducing
the student to mission tactics.
It is simple and a value
so it will be used again.
Here the subordinate is giving the mission
of getting his unit across the river.
Getting these unit across the river
is the output. The senior desires,
the that he has been given
crosses the nearest bridge.
The junior commander arrives at the
site to find that the bridge has been
destroyed. He does not stop. He
does not wait for new orders.
He does not request permission
to change his route.
He goes to the nearest Ford several
kilometers distance, and he crosses there.
He informed the senior, of course, as
soon as he can, but he does not wait.
Remember, mission orders are necessary
to give the tempo of operations,
the rapidity that it must have if we
are to keep the enemy off balance.
So that's a very simple example.
I tell Echo, hey, I need your,
I need your troops across that river.
Go across that bridge. You get there,
the bridges out. You're like,
oh, I'm still going to get
across the river. Here's,
let's find a put into the place we
can go across or let's make it happen.
And you're gonna make it happen.
Not going to bother me.
You're not going to call me back.
[inaudible] hey, the bridges out.
What you want me to do now that
something that, this is a little bit,
this is a little bit simplified because
the reality is if you are going to start
moving kilometers away from
where I anticipated you being,
you need to tell me that you're moving.
You need to tell me,
cause I might have other friendly
units in the area that might,
IX don't expect you, I might have be
dropping bombs in that area. So this is,
this is actually leaving out some critical
coordination that does have to happen,
but the initiative to make
it happen should happen.
Yeah, it seems like you, um,
like in the, in the process
of that decentralized command,
the person carrying out the order is,
it's kind of tis discretion how much
he's going to deviate when something
changes. Like he can't, he's,
of course he's going to deviate.
He's going to make those adjustments,
but you don't want to deviate too much.
Right. And honestly, if I was to
give you the directions, hey echo,
I need you to go on a car.
I need you cross the river.
I would literally give you some parameters
to work within. I'd say, don't go,
don't go further south in this area then
this road and don't go further north
and this, you can do whatever
you want inside of here.
So now you can do it and you can do
whatever you want inside that box. Yeah.
And how you always talk about you'll,
you'll say like,
why are you going across
the river as well?
And speaking of y, and here's
another example of mission orders.
This is an actual example.
Seize control of route six west of the
muddy river in order to destroy enemy
forces, attempting to escape from
company Bravo's zone of action.
So it's telling you the why,
that's what the,
in order to his notice
in the mission order,
the phrase in order to that is a very
important phrase and usually ought to go
in the mission order.
There's no rule that every mission
order contain the phrase in order to,
if you were told attack the enemy company
that you see in front of you would
probably be highly superfluous
to tell you why they are there.
They are a threat. Why waste the
breath, but usually your mission order,
we'll have the ability
to endure time better.
If you explained the subordinate
why he is carrying the mission out.
So you called this echo, turn into little
tactical genius over there, aren't you?
In order to,
this gives the order,
the quality that Erich von
Man Stein called longterm.
It can endure the test of time. Your
commander can lose communication with you,
yet you can still carry out his intent
because you know what he wanted and you
can continue to act within his intent
for a long time without checking back.
Understanding the why as briefed
by Lieutenant Colonel Echocharles.
Okay.
Fixed rules are not appropriate
in instructing how to us,
how to assign missions.
Too often students reject good ideas about
tactics because they cannot get their
thoughts to fit the format of the
operation order that is being demanded.
The important thing is that the mission
be clear compared to clarity format is
of little or no consequence.
And this is,
we talk about it in an extreme ownership,
these massive PowerPoint briefs that,
I mean hundreds literally,
you know, a hundred,
150 slides to try and make the,
to try and brief a mission when in the
leaders would waste so much time trying
to put these briefs together and,
and they would,
they wouldn't do the planning
where they're supposed to be doing.
They wouldn't be thinking they be building
PowerPoint slides and I've just had
to get these guys to think and stop,
stop working on the,
and I'm trying to match your font chop,
trying to equalize the Hughes on each
slide to make it look pretty. No,
don't care.
What I want you to do is think,
and I want clear clarity of mission
as the most important thing.
The matter of fact, I had
one guy was running training
and, and a guy says to me,
it's one of the, one of the tasks you new
commanders. And he says, Hey, you know,
what is it? What is it that you're looking
for in the brief? And he's, you know,
trying to figure out how many slides do
I want to see and what format do I want
to see?
And I said,
what I want for the brief is that
your men understand the operation.
Boom.
Back to the book, the
subordinate receiving that
order must be more talented.
Amateur troops, awkward, clumsy,
untrained troops cannot be expected
to carry out mission orders. Why?
Because as a result of their lack of
experience, they must be told what to do.
Only the professional experience leader
can know what to do without being told
what to do. Because we in the Marine
Corps, set our standards high.
We expected our subordinates will train
until they can perform under mission
orders. So just, I don't know if I made
this clear or if I breezed over this park.
Mission orders is exactly what we're
talking about when it comes to, hey,
just tell the person, this is what I
need done and this is why I want it done.
You figured out, as opposed to telling
them exactly what you them to do.
Commander's intent. Yes,
indeed. Commander's intent,
burdens of responsibility increase on
both sides on the part of the senior
committed.
So when you're doing mission orders,
the burden of responsibility increases
on the part of the senior commander and
on the part of the subordinate look first
at the senior commander operating with
mission orders,
his orders must be perfectly clear.
The onus is on the senior to define to
the junior what must be accomplished
without telling him how to do it.
The onus is not on the junior to
ferret out what his commander wants.
The senior must state what he wants,
otherwise he should not expect to get it.
Now, I actually, when I,
when I teach people this,
I tell them that the onus
is on the junior. And if,
if I tell you to do something and you
don't understand why you're doing it and
you don't understand what my intent is
and you still go on the field and try and
do it, I blame you. I mean, it's my fault
too, but we're both taking ownership.
Might even say we're taking
extreme ownership of the situation.
But really if your boss isn't telling
you why your why your why they're telling
you to do something, you just
raise your hand and ask, Hey boss,
what's your objective here?
What's your overall intent?
What's the commander's intent?
Because I want to make sure if
I lose communications with you,
I can continue to execute
towards your desired end state.
That's what we're looking for.
Thank you.
Okay.
An additional burden of responsibility
on the seniors that he must train his
subordinates and his unit
to operate as a team.
They are not going to be able to perform
mission orders without training another
new boarding of responsibilities that
he must expect his subordinates to make
mistakes.
He may not expect zero defects.
Wars are won by people, not
machines. People make mistakes.
If people are more afraid of making
mistakes than they are of exercising
initiative now and then they will not
take risks and they will not exercise
initiative. Furthermore,
they will not win in war.
Perhaps the most important
new responsibility that
is placed on the commander
who gives mission orders is that
he must trust his subordinates.
If trust breaks down,
the whole system breaks down.
So people ask me about
trust from time to time.
And it's absolutely, and I use, I
talk about relationships, The r word,
and that's what, that's
what, that's what it is.
And Lafe and I talked about the other
day on the podcast is that just building
trust, how the one of the best
ways to build trust as give it,
I give it.
And so that's what it goes back and forth.
And in the military you do that when
you're in the training environment,
when there's no risk or very,
very tiny risk of life and limb,
there's no strategic lift and you're not,
you'd risk,
you're not gonna lose the war.
So I'm going to let you run with stuff.
I want you to learn. I want you
to take risks. And if you fail,
if you screw something up, I don't try
and fire you. We try and learn from it.
And that encourages you to take
initiative and keep getting after it.
Okay.
Now the, the, we're moving
to the next section.
Yeah.
Which is called the main effort.
The commander in making his plan must
determine what and where his main effort
is in every operation, whether
it be offensive, defensive,
or withdrawal.
This main effort should be
specified in the operation order.
It should always be clearly
stated in paragraph three
a the concept of operation.
There can only be one main effort.
When you start giving two or
three or a three part main effort,
you'd better look back at it
because the chances are you do,
you have not made up your mind
what you are trying to do.
So if you're trying to plan a
mission, you, you're telling,
you're telling people there's three main
things we're trying to get done. No,
wrong. Yep. There should be one.
Yup. Yeah, in message, convenience.
Um, actually I think it's the newspaper
writing. They call it burying the lead.
So like your main story has to,
you know,
you can't have three main stories in one
article. Got It. Because, and you know,
one story is going to have
cool details, right? Right.
But you start spending a bunch
of time on these cool details.
They call that burying the lead.
It's a bad deal done
do that. Don't do the newspaper business
and don't do that on battlefield.
Every unit commander down to the company
commander will always assign a main
effort and sometimes even
a platoon commander should
the entire command must be
aware of what and where
the main effort is.
The commander can change
the main effort at any time.
This is what gives the operation its
fluidity in in. This is one of the
pretty common issues that we run.
It ran into it when I was
running training run into it.
Now in the business world where you've
worked with a company and they're not,
they're not assigning a main effort.
There were concentrating on 14
different things at the same time.
They don't prioritize and execute this.
This is another form of
prioritize and execute
and that's a problem because if
you're trying to do 14 things at once,
you're going to not
accomplish any of them.
The German word for main effort is shared,
pumped anytime in your readings.
When you see that and often you
will see it written in metallics.
The German word strip punked.
Take Note,
because it is one of the most important
underlying concepts in everything the
Germans do.
Make the main effort where
the enemy least expects you.
Make the enemy. Make the main
effort where the enemy is weak.
Be prepared to be surprised.
So let's go. I gotta,
I gotta stop right there.
It's interesting.
You know when you see the big fortified
area of the enemy, you see, okay,
we're going to, we better, we better
attack that hard. No wrong answer.
That's a surface.
We're looking for gaps.
So don't make the main
effort that the strong point,
make it the weak point back to the book.
Be Be prepared to be surprised.
Be Leery of the council.
Do not ever be surprised in war.
You will be surprised. The task
is to learn to deal with surprise.
If what you thought would be an enemy,
weakness becomes the enemy strength.
You should not be disrupted.
If your taxes tactics are fluid,
you can deal with surprise.
You will shift your main effort to
enemy weakness and go on through.
That is how the main
effort works in the office.
Yeah,
fluidity. Remember we've been hearing
a lot about in the Vietnam war,
the Viet Cong were too rigid.
They would just try,
their plan didn't have the fluidity.
The main efforts should
be directed against enemy
weakness, not enemies. Strength.
Here you see the interconnection
between the concepts,
the con connection between the concept
of the main effort and the concept of
surfaces and gaps. All the concepts
work together at the same time.
The main effort cannot be understood in
isolation from surfaces and gaps because
it is directed against enemy weakness.
Okay,
and another,
another one of the four laws combat
that we talk about in the book.
Extreme ownership is simplicity.
Simple back to the book.
Even the principal of simplicity can be
recognized in the concept of the main
effort. Instead of trying to do 10
different things, we are focusing on one.
There will be many other efforts
going on at the same time,
but all in some way directed at
making the main efforts succeed.
So what do you gain from this main effort?
You gain direction,
you great, you gain
fluidity, you gain speed,
and you prevent dissipating your
efforts all over the battlefield.
The way the polls did when
the Germans invaded Poland,
they tried to defend their
entire 800 mile front.
There was no main effort and by
trying to be strong everywhere,
they weren't fact strong.
Nowhere this trying to cover all the
bases is a common error in the amateur
commanders plan. It is a symptom
of avoidance of decision making,
avoidance of decision making.
So if you're not saying, hey,
here's what we're going to focus on,
your, you're just, wow, I'm going to wait.
I don't want to decide yet.
No, I'm not ready to commit.
By establishing a main effort,
you make a clear decision.
You obviate the necessity for junior
officers to keep asking for guidance.
If they know their commanders made effort,
they can continue to operate even though
communications may be cut and they can
continue to operate at a
high tempo because they need
not keep checking back for
new orders.
And here we get to a another something
you might recognize from from our book,
extreme ownership.
When the commander has made this decision,
he has done something very necessary.
He has done something very ethical.
He is assumed and taken responsibility
for what will happen if the battle goes
awry.
He cannot blame his subordinates.
He can only blame himself.
It was key who decided what was to be
done and designated a main effort in order
to do it.
Therefore,
it takes courage and moral character
decides to select a main effort.
That is why the weak commander and
the amateur so often fail to do this.
In fact,
the weak commander will actively avoid
choosing a main effort is very convenient
for the commander weekend character to
avoid selecting the main effort because
if the battle goes on favorably,
he can blame someone else for the mistake.
The commander who has taken the stand and
selected his own main effort cannot do
this. Therefore, in a sense,
the main effort is a moral commitment.
Taking some ownership by selecting the
main effort and you'd get a dig that,
okay,
the next concept in, again, you know him,
I'm cruising through this book like I
always do. Only reading, I don't know,
probably a very small percentage of it,
15% and there's a ton in here.
It actually has some very cool uh,
like exercises where it
gives you a scenario that's
happening and you go through
when you figured out what you would
do and it gives you a good solution.
So it's got, it's got, it's
a great book to look at.
The next lecture
is called the concept of the objective.
According to this chair do according to
the Joint Chiefs of staff publication
number one dictionary of
military and associated terms.
The objective is the physical object
of the action taken a definite tactical
feature seizure and are holding of which
is essential to the commanders plan.
That definition is clear enough.
Bazell Odell heart would have disagreed
with the JCS definition had one point in
his writings.
Ladelle heart stated the only
real objective is the enemy.
The Dell hearts statement is also quite
clear and especially when we realize
that whether we are attacking or
defending the problem is always the enemy.
Once the enemy has
taken out of the action,
defending and attacking
or no longer necessary.
Now
the, the, the, I guess
the controversy here,
if we could call it that,
is the objective not being a
specific piece of terrain. It's the,
the objective is the enemy.
But that being said,
the terrain of course is
extremely important. We must
use it to gain advantage,
but the object of the attack is the enemy.
The objective must be to take the
enemy out of action to destroy him,
to disarm him. We cannot not do that
simply by seizing a piece of training,
holding it.
We must be prepared to move continually
wherever necessary to confuse and
disrupt him through a
combination of fire and movement.
When the term objective appears,
it means an aiming point.
That towards which we direct our efforts
in order to best use the terrain to
accomplish our final goal,
the destruction of the enemy,
the ability to wisely select an objective
is the mark of a good commander.
The inability is the mark of an amateur
and history is replete with examples of
poorly selected objectives.
There were hills fought for bravely by
marines in Vietnam after they ceased
being of any tactical value.
Lives were thrown away
from meaningless terrain.
Terrain that did not meet either of
the two main criteria for selecting an
objective. The two main
criteria are one that is loot,
that it'd be useful to you
or to dear to your enemy.
If it is neither one of these,
it is probably not worth the life of a
single marine and good commander will
therefore select terrain
that is useful to him.
The great commander will have the ability
to select terrain that is dear to the
enemy.
In the final concept is
the concept of the reserve,
General JFC follower of the British army.
The original author of the nine principles
of war that the US army was to adopt
in the 1920s once stated that of
all the principles he developed,
the most important was economy of force.
He reasoned that whichever side still
had forces left after the other sides had
been committed,
was bound to win.
Napoleon seems to have had similar
thoughts when he observed that whoever's
still had his reserve remaining after
his enemy had committed his reserve would
win the battle.
And here's another quote in here from
Napoleon that I think when they're talking
about committing, and it talks about
your mindset on the battlefield
from Napoleon,
if I appear to be always ready to reply
to everything it is because before
undertaking anything,
I have meditated for a long time.
I have foreseen what might happen.
It is not a spirit which suddenly reveals
to me what I have to say or do in a
circumstances, in a circumstance,
unexpected by others.
It is reflection,
a meditation.
So Napoleon, he was good to have these
quick reactions and everyone says, wow,
he must've just had this incredible,
you know, he's calling a spirit.
This comes to him and says,
Hey, move these guys over
here. Hey, assault that flank.
No. Here. He fought through this thing for
hours and he said, Oh, if they do this,
I'm gonna do that. If they come over
here, I'll move you. Ready over here.
Hmm.
Preparation.
What Napoleon was saying was that thorough
thought in advance prepared him to
make split second decisions when
the situation suddenly changed.
Okay.
Preparation.
Preparation is key.
Yeah.
Now.
That wraps up the book and I hope that
it provides some reminders and some
insight to people not only to the
war fighters out on the battlefield,
but as I said in the beginning,
I hope it provides some details
into dealing with humans,
with people and problems
in the business world,
in leadership positions on
that, Jiu Jitsu, Matt, in life,
whatever you're doing or whatever
you're trying to get done.
Think of how you can use maneuver
warfare to make it happen.
I guess we cannot
go over to some,
some questions from the interwebs and
I guess before we go to the interwebs,
maybe you could tell us
about the inner webs and
what we can do to support support
by being on the interwebs.
If you're on the interwebs and you're in
the mood to support this podcast and or
yourself
with supplementation,
go to on it.com/jocko
get on it.
Supplements are the best
ones. I like that idea. Yeah,
that's a good idea. Krill oil for
sure, for your joints, get tough.
Bring some of that Alpha
brainy shroom tech sport
mode. Yeah, shroom tech sport.
If you're into performance,
physical activity performance,
if you feel you need a little turbo
boost. Yeah, it was funny. Remember
Tim Kennedy put it in like real, real
good terms in my opinion when he use like,
oh yeah, when I took the
shroom tech, it's kind of like,
cause okay, so you don't want to
get confused and be like, Hey,
I'm gonna take the shroom tech in.
It's like a,
like a caffeine boost or something.
You know, you don't because it's not,
that's not so it's an, and he put it in
these terms where he's like, you know, he,
you go a few rounds, you go five,
six, seven, eight, you know,
however many rounds and everyone's like
real poop. But then you're kind of like,
I can go a few more routes. And really
that is exactly how it is this room.
But when you're hitting towards
the end of the round or whatever,
it's like you feel
solid, you know, it just,
I guess apparently what it does is it
helps you utilize your oxygen consumption.
You'll find a site or whatever. I mean,
obviously you're talking about Jujitsu,
which for those people that don't
train Jujitsu, which you should,
but if you don't,
well you should,
but you are also going to keep working
out and you have the, you know, you,
so sort of a metabolic conditioning
type type of workout situation going on.
That's true.
Remember how I was telling you I did my
met come metabolic conditioning after I
like normal lifting. So person doing the
reverse of that lately. Really. I Dunno,
I would advise Alan super warmed
up. I'm dripping with sweat. Yeah.
And I feel really good and I figure
maybe the opposite will happen because we
both know if you go with your,
with your strength movements first you
tick a little bit off your met construct.
Right? Yeah. If, if you do.
And so that way when you do the metcon
fresh, you feel like Superman, right?
Cause you're yeah.
Blasted your muscles out.
So I've been doing the reverse though.
What?
I'm doing the metcon type first and then
I just breathe it out and then I get
into the heavy stuff.
Yeah. And I dig it on.
The only reason I say I dig it
because you're a savage like that.
But consider cause those are two,
well it depends.
It depends on what kind of lifting
you're doing. So let's say if not,
well if you're lifting like
for strength or or you know,
muscle growth or whatever,
you should do that first because the
results that you seek are inline with you
having full energy. You lifting. I agree
with you. I actually think you're correct.
And the METCON isn't,
the results of the metcon is for you
to recover from conditioning. So he,
it's muscular conditioning. So if you're
tired going in, that's more conditioning.
You have to recover from better exercise.
So it slowed essentially. But Hey,
if you want to reverse it, give your
body some, some, some stuff to show.
Cause I,
I completely agree with you and I've
only been doing this for a couple months
and I, or you know what it was, you don't
know. It was one day I was, I was in,
I did like a metcon was pretty strong
feeling good. Sure. And then I got done.
I said I need a little bit more. So I
was like, I'm just going to move some,
you know, some, some heavy get
my liftoff. And when I, when I
went heavy I was like, man, that feels
good. Right? All loose them all warm.
And so now I've just kind of
started doing it a little bit.
Yeah. And if you get
used to that, then it,
it'll start to be more and more benefit.
I used to,
I used to run on the treadmill.
I used to do like three and a half miles,
someone's four miles and then Lyft,
just because I didn't have time and I,
every time I lift that I would never
feel like running the, you know,
the mileage afterwards. I do it on a
treadmill and sweat. So I'd be like,
you know what,
I'm going to get the,
the running out of the way that I'm
going to lift. And then I was like, Dang,
lifting is,
it's kind of harder,
but I'd way rather endure this
discomfort when I'm lifting.
Then when I'm running on the treadmill.
But I did that for months and months and
months. And then one day I didn't run.
I was like, it was weird. It was like
stiff. Yeah. So you kinda get used to it.
But either way. I mean, my original
point is w I w I do the met now.
I do the math on after I left
during the metcon, after I live.
That has been my standard for so long.
Right.
But you know how you'd say do
the metcon before you lift or,
or you're just doing the metcon that day.
It's easier because you're not
as tired from lifting. Yeah.
Yeah. But, um, anyway, my, my
original point was the shroom tech.
So if you're doing that kind
of thing after you lift,
when you're going into the metcon,
you're going to feel way better.
You want to hear something cool.
So a lot of times people ask me,
what is your workout?
Right.
They want to know reps sets
weights. Yeah. Right. Yeah.
That's cool. Of course. Um, and I
haven't, I haven't put it out there for
[inaudible].
I got a book.
I'm putting together a book that's
going to have book kind of thing. Yeah.
She's not going to be, the ebooks
can be a real book. Hardcover. Yeah.
I like a real legit book on,
um,
which means going to
take a little more time,
but I'd rather do it and do it right.
But what's interesting is this is
what's so cool. So people that,
people that listen to podcasts and
asking it hadn't been applying the basic
principles because I have never put it,
I haven't put out,
I don't think I've put out a
single workout. Also, people say,
what do you actually eat? Right? They want
to know what I had for breakfast, lunch,
dinner, what I had for snacks, whatever.
All I say is like, Oh, you know, I mostly,
you know, Aye. Aye. Aye. Low, very
low carbs. I eat a lot of meat.
I do a lot of protein. I need a lot of
fat. Okay, what do you do for workouts?
I get up early in the morning,
I hit it hard, you know,
am I doing squats and doing pull ups
and doing, did basic stuff. Right.
And I've put those basic
principles out there. Well,
there's people troopers that had been
applying these basic principles and
they're making incredible progress in
their lives. They're getting stronger,
they're getting leaner,
they're getting in better shape.
So it's actually proven,
cause I remember you and I talked about
this as long time ago. I said, listen,
it's more about the commander's intent,
right?
The working I was about the
commander's intent. It's not about,
I'm going to tell you how
many reps and sets to do,
I'm going to tell you what you want to
make happen, right? I'm going
to tell you where you want,
where you want to be at the end of this
workout physically and mentally and,
and people have been taking that.
And I mean all kinds of people,
they have lost 28 pounds.
I've lost 42 pounds just from
applying the basic principles that I,
and and so those will be consolidated in
the book so that people can follow them.
And there'll be some other
good stuff in the book too.
Basic philosophy of couple philosophy.
Yeah.
Well that was kind of a tangent on, on
it, wasn't it? Well aid, rightly so.
I think right, that he, so I think
it's, it's convenient, right? Which,
which actually kind of brings me to my
point that consistency is probably the
most overlooked. That even though people
know, yeah, you gotta be consistent.
We got an a, but that's kind of everything
because everything else is variable.
Like you can,
you can see there's a billion
different work consistency.
Do you mean
doing the same thing or you
just mean doing it every day?
Getting in there and yeah, absolutely
not skipping days, weeks, you know,
getting off the horse, you
know, that kind of stuff.
There's a million different workouts you
can do that will give you results and
there's a million different
results that you can,
you can kind of strive for and
get him cause it just so many.
Same thing with diet,
like you can, you know,
people have their rigid diet philosophy,
but the fact is that many
different diets work. Yeah.
I mean there's some basic principles.
You don't need a bunch of sugar.
You don't need a bunch of fast
food. You don't, you know,
the obvious things to avoid and you can
get results with many kinds of data and
I would go one step further or what
you're talking about is consistency in,
in order to have consistency
that requires the distance.
It does require the discipline. So that's
the key factor. That is the key factor.
And when people apply the discipline to
their lives, boom, right now we got you.
Becomes consistent and that's everything.
Yep. So the books can comment in.
The books can talk about
that. There you go. Boom.
How well it's going to
support the podcast. If you,
before you do your Amazon shopping,
go to Jocko podcast.com or or one of
the websites, chocolate store.com.
Click on the Amazon link
and do your shopping.
You getting support passively and you
can install that little tool or you can
just make it your foot fit
year up. I put it in my, my,
what's that called up at the
top of bookmarks? Bookmark.
Just so when I click on Amazon, it's
already the Jaguar. Yeah, yeah, exactly.
That's what I, yeah, we go crazy
with Amazon and housing units.
So awesome. And don't call it a little
tool. It's not a little tool. Oh,
that's right. It's the
trooper tool. It's a big deal.
It's pretty little technically.
It's really, anyway,
the trooper tool that Brady made,
little things for that again. Yeah.
Little small tool. Simple. Um, you
go and you can go on the and get it.
It's called the Jocko
podcast trooper tool. Chrome
extension. What it all it does,
it makes it easy to support podcasts
when you do your Amazon shopping,
so you don't have to remember that and it,
you know, it basically you click on it,
do you want this tool? Click yes. Boom.
It's on your little browser. There.
It automatically directly to our,
our affiliate link,
which senior support that way. And it's
kind of cool little icon if you, if you,
um, yeah, when you do it, this little
icon there, it makes it official,
but you can hide the icon if you don't
want it to decide if he knows what,
if you don't want it, and I understand
it if you don't. Yeah. It's telcos face,
but you know, yeah. The trooper
tool. That's a, that's a
good one. That's good. Easy,
easy way.
Because remembering to go to the
website and click through before you do,
you know how like you're, yeah. You know,
you just like Amazon or it's,
you know, I want this thing,
I want that duct tape. Nope. Nope.
Same Day deal. Yeah, that's true.
So anyway, now you've got the
trooper tool. Boom. Easy, easy. Um,
also all the,
obviously by subscribing to the podcast
if you haven't already owns a good way
to support. Yeah, absolutely.
And um, the Jocko store,
that's a good one. I think if you like
shirts that say discipline equals freedom.
Most people do have to wear shirts at
some juncture during the day. Sure.
You can't get into the
restaurant without attention.
Uncle I use sometimes accepted, but
yeah, there's some shirts on there.
If you like them, get a shirt. That's a
good way to support or a bumper sticker.
Elections coming up.
Chocolate toilet, six days.
Yeah. I saw a car with Jocko 2016 on
it. Did you know the purpose today?
Is it in San Diego? Yeah, Chris
Martin, but still it's cool to see.
You know when you pull up you're like,
oh, that's Chris Martin's car. Anyway,
it looked cool. He has a nice car too,
by the way, so it looked extra cool.
You know, it was like extra official.
Yeah. We got some real supporter.
That's what it felt like.
Also,
subscribe to the Youtube Channel
and you posted your first,
I'm starting to put it, it's
a, it's a deleted scene.
Does it? Difference can be
tight on those deleted scene.
If you want to hear Echo Charles
talking about the keys being abduction.
It's my kids podcasts.
There are about alien abduction.
There's a lot of podcasts about it.
Is that a son and I have glory cause now
we're going to fit in that subcategory.
Leadership war darkness
and alien abduction.
Maybe that's why it's an outtake that
was more like an example underlying kind
of thing. It was more about my children's
book idea. Okay. We're good. We're good.
Anyway, those are the ways.
Yep. [inaudible] dot com
slash Jocko that's a good one.
Like I said for the supplement,
10% off. I forgot to mention that.
If you don't know 10% off
the supplements. Yeah. Good.
I guess with that,
let's get down to the questions
from the troopers on the interwebs.
Get a lot of questions lately
that I like it. I like it too.
First question,
Jocko,
if you were coaching Mcgregor for those,
don't know, that's Conor Mcgregor,
UFC fighter,
what would you focus on to try
and make up the Jujitsu disparity?
All defense. Hmm, interesting.
And if you don't know what's going on,
Conor McGregor is fighting Nate
Diaz again, two oh two UFC.
So a lot of times I don't like to talk
about this kind of thing because it's,
by the time this comes out,
it'll be you.
By the time you're listening to this
might be over, don't care anymore.
But there is a,
a principal here at concept behind this
that does make sense to try and discuss
so people can learn and improve.
And something for me
to think about my game.
So you've got this guy who's a really
good striker going against a guy who's a
pretty good striker himself.
Very good. Yeah, very good.
And that's one of the things that this is,
this is the question,
the way it sets it up,
as if Jujitsu is the,
is the only thing that
Nate Diaz is better at,
that might not necessarily be the truth.
And in fact, in their first fight,
it was the striking of Nate Diaz that
forced Conor McGregor to shoot a sloppy
takedown, take it to ground.
And once he got on the ground,
the Jujitsu from Nate Diaz was just
way too much for, for Mcgregor.
So this question,
it's almost a little bit off because the
question shouldn't be that there's just
a Jujitsu disparity. The
question should be, you know,
what is, how would you make
up for the fighting disparity?
Or maybe not even that.
It's, how would you go against,
what would you tell Connor?
What would you work at all this strategy?
So let's just look at it as
an overall strategic question.
You've got a guy that's pretty,
that's what, what, what is he good at?
That's the question of
what is he going to,
one of the strengths of Conor
McGregor, he's fast, he's strong,
but strong might not even come to play
because our Diaz as walking around at 200
pounds right now they're finding one's 70.
So he's gonna have to cut a lot of weight.
He's going to be big and strong.
He's going to be a better
shape for this fight. Uh,
Connor is pretty good with
some unorthodox stuff.
His striking is fast and fairly dynamic.
So those are the things
that he has going for him.
What does Nate Diaz have going for him?
His jujitsu is really good,
really good at it,
too sick.
His striking his, especially his
boxing, he did not a big kicker.
So if I was, if I was McGregor, here's
what I'd be doing. I mean, what?
I'd be working my wrestling, we'll
be working on under hooks, of course,
in,
in getting control and getting back to
my feet when I get taken down immediately
getting back to my feet,
the way I would fight if I was Conor
McGregor is I would back off with the hard
punches.
I would throw a lot of really fast light
punches and I move around a lot and
just try and touch and go. That's
what I do. If I was Conor Mcgregor,
I would possibly starting in the middle
of the second round, the third round,
five round fight, I might start
throwing some leg kicks. He doesn't,
Nate sometimes doesn't even check leg
kicks so maybe you can start putting on
hurting on him if you,
if you throw enough of those.
But in Jujitsu wise I would
teach him to disengage,
disengage cause you don't want to go.
You don't want to get in the Ooda loop,
wouldn't he?
That Mcgregor does not want to get in
an ou to loop situation with with ds
because he can't keep up with
him. He'll be, he'll be changing.
There'll be going to the next thing,
going to the next thing,
go to the next thing to the next thing
and condom Burgerlands get caught behind
and heal.
Won't be able to do it.
So I teach them to get now one thing that
does make Jujitsu a little bit harder
if you're, if you and I are doing Jujitsu
and your goal, you're not trying you,
you actually disengage from me and
you're just like your whole goal.
If we were on the mat shook hands,
slapped,
bump and we're going to roll and all
you did try to do is stay away from me,
it would be a really hard round for me.
It would be harder than
if you attacked me. Yeah.
It's harder than if you attacked
me and when I did take you down,
all you did was try and get back up.
You didn't try and close the Guardian
trying to attack me with any submissions.
You just tried to get back
up and get away from me.
That is a much harder round for me.
Then if you actually come at me with
your full board Jujitsu because then it's
Hugh Jitsu versus you did too
and I have an advantage. Yup.
But if it's Jujitsu of mine
versus run away from you,
now I've got to run after you. Now
it's, it's, it's a more fair fight.
So that's what,
that's what Mcgregor needs to do.
He needs to use his speed and his,
yeah, use his speed and that, I
think that's his biggest advantage.
The other thing that I,
the other thing that I find about the
Diaz brothers that I wished that I could,
I could,
I wish they,
I wish they would not trained so much
triathlon and train more explosiveness.
I wish she was a little bit strong
or both Nate and nick. I mean,
those guys are awesome and they're,
they're great fighters, but they've,
they really train.
They do.
They do literally do triathlons and so
you're not getting explosive muscles.
Now it shows that they have great cardio,
but I'd rather just,
they were a little bit more explosive.
That's, that's my personal opinion.
Yeah, I dig it. I have no advice.
I think Nate Diaz is so well rounded
in this. As far as this matchup goes.
I don't know.
Like, just like that first fight
Amea. The first fight though,
you watched the first round. It's
not easy. It's not a pushover.
It's going to be a tough fight,
man. Yeah. That's in the end.
That's not what I'm saying at all. I'm
saying he's making sure as far, you know,
you know how like you, you know, you,
you attack the weaker points, right?
Like let's say I'm a way better striker
than one guy and his Jujitsu is way
better than mine. I can
stay on it, you know,
it's obvious that's where I'm an attack.
But in this case it's not like that.
So I'm not, yeah. I Dunno man. The cell
phone. Yeah. It's a tough fight for it.
For Connor as tough favor for
Nate to, I mean, there were some,
yeah. Yeah. Even though the ending of
the fight was very lopsided, right.
The, the, the first round, it was a
little closer and I think Connor fought,
he had magic thought that
some of them even said it.
A post fight press conference. He said,
you know, he was the big man, right.
And, and I, I hit him
with everything or not.
And most of those would stop a smaller
man. Yup. They didn't stop him.
And I think that's gotta be,
that's gotta be hard. Yeah.
I think that got to them psychologically.
So if he's prepared for that
psychologically this time,
maybe he'll be able to stick with
a game plan and not shoot. Yeah.
On him, which was ridiculous. Yeah. And
even the shoot, it wasn't just like, Hey,
I'm going to decide to shoot. It was
kind of like a ditch ditch effort. Yeah.
Kind of kind of rock too.
And now you,
you shoot your rock and you
have to contend with Nate
Diaz Jujitsu. So it's like,
it's not just, I got to continue with Nate
Diaz did you too, which is bad enough,
by the way, but you're rocked and
it was like a desperation thing.
Then you've got to deal with it. Then
you get that. So it seemed like, oh,
was so quick,
but it was like,
it was just a bunch of compounding
factors and culminated in that,
that joke didn't work out. Looking forward
to watching that. Yeah. All right, great.
Next question, Jocko. Like you,
many leaders began as rebels,
chocolates. The Rep will tell
you about his band one day.
How did you learn to see the game? Yeah,
man. That Elgin told you about. Yeah, man.
And that you told me about too.
How did you learn to see the game and
are rule followers at a disadvantage?
Okay. So yeah, I was a rebellious youth
and you know, when I got in the
seal teams, I was kind of a rebel,
a rebel as well.
And as a matter of fact,
if you think about it from
a certain perspective,
being in special operations,
especially when I came in,
being in special operations is almost
a form of rebellion in its own right.
Because you're saying, look, the regular
stuff, we'll do the regular stuff. Right,
right. We'll do the other stuff. Yeah. So
that was my attitude. You know, I thought
all the regular navy, Nah, I'm doing.
Yes. You know? So that was my rebellion
and, and, and like I've explained before,
joining the military, I grew up in,
in New England, not lot of, not a huge
military proponent up there.
And so that was,
it was almost rebellious
thing. It, matter of fact,
it was a rebellious thing for me to
join the military in the first place.
So these are the kinds of things that
were rebellious and yes, we were,
we were my buddies in the word rebel
youth with some rebellious rock and roll
bands back in the day.
So
when I got to the seal teams, we
actually were, I kind of maintained that,
you know, like we're going to be hardcore.
We meet, maybe the word isn't rebel,
but we were, we were
like outsiders, you know,
we were like going hard and the group
of guys I was with when the guy was,
I went through seal training with that,
went to seal team one with
me back in the day. Uh,
you know, we, we, we were
getting after it. We were
pushing hard, we were, you know,
being hardcore and I actually got told
to stand down a few times for doing stuff
that was a little bit too hardcore
and it's a matter of fact.
So you get these evaluations in the, in
the navy, when I first got in the navy,
that is old evaluation system where you
had 15 things you were getting evaluated
on and everybody, it, it
had been um, in inflation.
So highest grade you could get as a 4.0.
So there was an inflation
of the grades at the time.
And so everyone just put 4.0
for everything pretty much.
And I actually, I have this, I
actually saved this evaluation of me,
but I got a three, eight,
3.8 in team building.
And the guy that gave it
to me said, uh, you know,
you're just, you're just too
hard on people that are unsat.
Which I actually, he was one of the guys
that I was like, you know, hard on. Yeah,
it was hard on him. So an UNSAT, I
used to use that word all the time,
sat, run, ceremony. So that
was sort of, you know, we were,
we were rebelling by being super
hardcore, I guess you could say. But then
even though I was rebellious,
and again, that's a strong word.
I don't know if that's the word we were,
I don't know if that's the perfect word,
but I did. I loved the seal
teams. Right. So in, in,
in working for some of the
great guys that I worked for,
I realize that if you
want to impact the teams,
which I want to do
because I did love teams,
then you got to try and get into some
kind of leadership position. You know,
these guys that I respected that
I worked for us a day, wait,
that guy controls of this platoon,
I want to do that. He's helping us,
he's making as good.
So kind of like that old quote that
the best form of revenge is success.
It's almost like the best
form of rebellion is success.
And so that's what I kind of went for
it to a situation I was trying to,
for a situation where I could move
forward and kind of bring this, hey,
I got this now. This is my
platoon. Who'd, you know?
So I guess that was a little bit of a,
there's a little bit simplified but,
but you know,
I don't want to get,
I don't want to make it sound like I
was some kind of crazy revel in the seal
teams. I wasn't, I was, I
was into the seal teams,
I was into doing the right
thing and I wanted to do the,
do my best in the seal teams.
So I guess that's not really
being rebellious at all.
But I did still have some
of that rebel mindset.
And one of the things I
think is beneficial about
having a rebel mindset is you
questioned things,
you question things you're not allowed to.
I was never afraid to say no
or I don't agree with that.
I was never afraid to be
contrarian or something.
I was never afraid to hold the line and
take criticism. So that goes even if,
if you're in a group of rebels
and you go against them,
who's the rebel now?
Well you are.
So when guys would be going
down a certain path, I wouldn't,
I'd be okay holding the line against
them because I was okay with being an
outsider. I guess that's the word I've
been looking for. Like an outsider,
someone that's not quite just following
and doing what everyone else is doing.
I've always been okay
with being an outsider.
So maybe it's not necessarily a rebel,
but being an outsider and like, okay,
those guys are doing it that
way. No, I don't agree with that.
And I'm okay being over here by
myself marching to my own drum,
for lack of a better word.
But it's kind of like only if you
need to be kind of thing. Right.
What do you mean?
Like if everyone's doing the right thing,
you're going to go with that and
you're going to go hard the way you do.
But yeah, you're not just like this
follow the fall, right in line. You know?
And I never,
I would say that's something.
And so if we categorize that as
being rebellious than yes, I kind of,
I would more categorize it with being
comfortable with being an outsider.
Yeah. Comfortable with my own
decision making process. So,
and not always. I mean, there was times
where I did things that other one,
you know, when I was younger, you're
not. That's another thing when, um,
you know, you hear me talk,
I'm 44 years old, right?
I spent my whole adult
life in the seal teams.
I didn't show up in the seal teams
with like this incredible leadership
capability and ready to write a book. No,
man, I learned this stuff. I'm learning,
I'm still learning. I'm still learning
this stuff. I picked up off along the way.
So I don't want people to ever think that,
you know,
I was a superstar.
I'm still not, I'm just,
I have an open mind,
but now I can look back and I was lucky
enough to have some great jobs and some
great experiences that opened a lot of,
uh,
it showed me have to,
I learned a lot. I, I,
I had an open mind and the world
taught me a lot of stuff. And so,
uh, yeah, but it wasn't,
it wasn't just, hey I
was showed up there.
But I would say this,
the lead people that are out there,
data leaders keep the revel alive.
Keep it alive, keep them
under control. Yeah.
And maybe you don't let the rebel
talk to other people. Right.
Maybe. And I've, I've had seal
buddies that do this where they're,
they're rebellious. There was outsider
or whatever the word we're using as I am,
but they just can't keep it inside.
So they're verbalizing it and there.
And what are they doing? They're making
enemies. You know, they're making their,
their antagonizing people.
They're doing that.
I never did that cause
I'm playing the game.
I'm going to win the
long term strategic goal.
So don't let the rebel be the one that
represents you and talks and opened your
mouth,
but let them whisper in
your ear and listen to,
yeah,
I talked to him to get policy.
I talked to my wife a
lot about the difference.
There's a difference between what you
think or what you feel or whatever and
what, how you behave. So like you
can, like if you, I don't know,
you get cut off
in traffic or something,
no one's going to be mad at you if you're
like mad at that or if that irritates
you or whatever. But if you
start flipping the guy off or or,
or violating traffic laws to go chase
them or do you know to start behaving
because he cut you behaving a
certain way then that that's wrong.
So there's a difference.
You can feel like all kinds of stuff,
but once you start misbehaving,
that's when the violations come up.
Basically what you're saying, like don't,
don't let him control your drag. Drag.
Yeah. Your behavior, mine control. Think
we've talked about that on here before.
A little by control body control too.
Yeah.
They're just being a rebel
typically. That's like, Hey,
all these rules that everyone's following,
I'm going to,
I rebel against those rules.
But here's the thing.
Some of those rules are good rules.
Exactly.
So you can't just be a rebel to
bone on bone Lincoln statement.
I'm a rebel and that's why, that's why
I was kind of pulling back on that word.
Makes me sound like I was
big rebel. I was not. I was,
I loved being the teams. Right.
So why would I rebel against it?
The people I rebelled against where
the guys that were not good seals,
we were developed against them.
Like I told you,
we had a mute me that was
a rebellion rebellion.
Had a real legit mutiny when against
our commanding are our platoon commander
and said, hey to the commanding officer
said, no, we don't want this guy anymore.
That's, that's a wrap. Yeah. We
rebelled. But then again, everyone,
I'm a platoon was with me, so we all
were about, so then it was I rebel. Yeah.
And does that make you a rebel?
Just cause you rebelled at one time,
you know? Yeah. I get it. Think we're
getting into too much semantics.
Aren't 108th semantics kind
of part of let's not go there.
All right, next question, Jacqueline.
How do you deal with the leader who
preaches ownership but does not practice
ownership? Oh, drag.
The leader who preaches ownership
but does not practice ownership.
You know what I do in those situations?
I take ownership myself and I worked for
all kinds of bosses that didn't want to
take ownership and you know what? I
did take ownership. I took ownership.
You worked for a Boston doesn't
want to lead. You know what I did?
If for in my mind,
if a boss doesn't step up or doesn't
take ownership, they're not a problem.
They're an opportunity.
They are an opportunity.
It's an opportunity for me to step.
If you're not,
if you're my leader and you're
not giving me instruction,
you're not stepping up and leading,
guess what? I'm going to run with it.
I'm going to run. I'm going to take
control. I'm going to take command.
I'm going to make things happen,
and you're either going to,
you're either going to see what I'm doing
and say, wow, he's taking ownership.
I need to step up.
Or
if he doesn't have any potential at all,
then maybe he looks at it and says,
mmm,
you know what?
Maybe I'm not fit for this.
Or maybe they don't
realize it's happening.
You'll end up taking their job from them
because other people will eventually
realize. Now the thing that
you have to be careful of
is if you say, oh, he's not
leading, I'm going to lead.
Then you let your ego starts saying I'm
the leader and then you flaunt it and
now you might make your boss think
that you're gunning for their job
and then we can have some issues because
now he might shut you down. He might,
you know, there's all kinds of things like
negative things that can happen there.
So when you take ownership,
you've got to make sure you're putting
your ego in check and make sure that
you're taking ownership,
but you're still giving them the credit.
That's the hardest thing to do,
but it works. I'm telling you,
I promise you that works
if you take ownership,
but then you'd give him the
credit like, Hey sir, you know,
I just wanted to go through
this thing right here.
Here's what I did yesterday based on,
you know, the guidance that you gave us.
The guy didn't give you any guidance,
but you just make it up. Biz, make it up.
He's, you know, here we go and you just
do your best to make him look good.
Eventually you're going to win. So if
you've got someone that's not leading,
that's not stepping up, that's not
taking ownership, just do it yourself.
Do it in a tactful manner.
Do it in a non ego flare up manner,
but do it. Make it happen.
Get after it. Yeah.
If you keep that goal, you know how
like when you're on a team, right?
You have some objectives
and it's probably,
there's just a handful of them typically
if not just one close with and destroy
the enemy. Yup. Yeah. Make the sale,
you know, whatever the goal is.
If you keep the goal in mind,
then you as long as you'd like,
really keep it in mind you, you can avoid
all these because if you're like, okay,
I'm going to step out.
Just like are you saying I'm going
to step up and lead and if your
goal shifts from the,
the main goal that you guys all have
to now my new goal is to be the leader.
That's my goal,
to be the leader.
Then up comes the ego
because the being the leader,
that's what you're focused on. I'm the
leader. You're the follower kind of thing.
Keep the goal in mind. You're going
to do basically with your ownership.
You're going to do your
part and then some,
if someone's not doing certain things or
whatever, you're going to take the lead.
You're going to do your job
in it to achieve the goal.
Therefore, pulling
everybody ahead. Keep that,
keep that goal in mind there. Yes,
indeed. They do it for the goal,
not for yourself. Yeah. Good.
Jocko,
something that would be very interested
in listening to you discuss is the art
of disarming people with words
not hand.
Yeah,
and good question.
How do we,
how do we disarm people and good thing.
Tonight we talked about maneuver warfare
because we already know that we're not
going to attack the strong point.
We're going to look for the gaps.
We're going to look for the weaknesses.
We're going to look for the openings.
So what does that mean?
That means if we're dealing
with someone that has a big ego,
we're going to sidestep that. We might
even throw some compliments out there.
I might be saying, Echo, you're so
good at they do, and that's right here.
I could use some help doing that and
now we're getting around his ego.
Now we can start getting into his head.
If the person's over aggressive,
maybe you just have to be a
little bit more accepting of them.
Maybe if they're nervous, you've got
to just reassure him they're hostile.
Be just be open minded
to what they're saying.
So there's a lot of ways that disarm him,
like some tactical things did.
You could literally, like it
says, disarm people with words,
so what are words? Disarm people? I'll
give you a couple. That's a good idea.
Oh, okay. Or yeah, that
actually makes good guy that,
that's good sense right there. That makes
sense. Right? And disarmed or, Oh yeah,
I like that. Disarmed. Right? All
three of those little easy phrase.
That's a good idea. That makes
sense. You know, I liked that.
Those are all things that are going
to disarm somebody a little bit.
And once you disarm them,
they're going to,
they're going to open up, they're
gonna open up a little bit. So, so like
once you,
you're going to be,
once you get them disarmed
by just opening your mind,
giving them a little compliment tome
that you like with winter coming with
coming from,
and then you start to probe and trying
to figure out what's going on at eight
instead of being direct, right? We
want to use the indirect method here.
So you know, ask questions. Say,
Hey Echo, could you explain
to me what, what the,
what we're trying to get done here.
That's a lot different than
what are you trying to do here?
That's an attack almost.
What the hell were you thinking?
What the hell were you
thinking? Hmm. Hey, could you
explain to me this?
Cause I'm not sure I understood it.
I didn't really see everything here.
Or Hey,
I'm having trouble understanding
this. Can you, can you help me?
Cause I'm not sure. I don't think I get
this. So now when I say that to you,
you, in order to explain something, you
have to actually open up. You have to say,
okay, I'll find, I'll tell you,
well that as soon as you say that now
you're opened up right now you open up and
when you open yourself up,
will you open yourself up verbally
with an idea to explain an idea,
then you're opening
yourself up mentally too.
Cause now we're having a discussion and
that's what I'm trying to make happen.
So it's pretty easy.
I shouldn't say it's pretty easy if you
think about it and you just think about
those simple phrases that you
can use to disarm people of,
hey, it's good idea. I like where you're
coming from. All the have that, that,
that actually, that makes good sense.
Or that is the way you disarm somebody.
Very simple. Yeah. And there's
little things you can do
even outside actually outside,
straight up,
outside of any specific like scenario
where you know how some people are just
more approachable than other people.
And then some people just aren't.
So what you can do,
and what I've noticed is people that
don't talk negatively about people and
don't come in just talking negative
in general, like I knew a guy or no,
I still know him, but I don't
see him anymore hardly. But
every time he'd come in,
the first thing out of his mouth
was something like, I don't know,
traffic was bad, it was something bad. You
know, he's just complaining about life.
And it was just a matter
of what particular thing
he chose to complain about.
But it was always a complaint. Everything.
And another thing he would do is,
let's say someone would say something,
oh, hey, did you see this or that,
or whatever. This is. This was
real cool. He'd be like, yeah, but,
and then say something bad and kind of
dump on it, you know? Yeah, that's true.
But you know, that kind of stuff. So
don't do that. So that seems kind of easy,
but you'd be surprised where
don't be super negative. Don't be,
don't be a negative person in general.
So right off the bat,
you'll be kind of one of those guys
that's more approachable. But here's,
here's the one that's harder.
I mean it's simple,
but it's kind of harder to do because I
think it comes kind of natural and easy.
We'll not easy is don't
talk bad about people.
And when people were talking bad about
people like to you or around you or
whatever, don't like jump in
and kind of accommodate them.
And I'm not saying reject them or even
talk bad about them talking bad about you.
I don't, don't do that. Just don't be
one of those people. Yeah, it's the,
here's the thing,
it's,
I'm going above and beyond
saying don't be, you know,
certain people, that's all they do
is gossip about people. Of course.
That's a no brainer. I'm saying never do
it. Try to never do it at, at any cost.
Never do it if you can.
Cause basically you're trying to
establish a rep of being this positive,
approachable person. That's
what you're trying to do. So,
even though people don't take
specific mental like, Oh,
you're talking bad about this person, you
always talk bad about people, the fee,
you feel it. So you ever, you ever
been around somebody who tells,
tells you secrets every time
they see you, like, Hey,
I'm not supposed to tell you this
but this. And you're like, Dang,
this guy's telling me you know, all this
cool secrets. I like being around them.
And that's typically why people told him,
I'm never going to tell him any secrets.
That's exactly right. So you know,
this guy talking about about people or
this guy's being negative or whatever,
when it comes to you,
why,
why would I want to trust in this
guy or talk to this guy about this,
especially if we're going to do
something together. You know,
we're kind of coming at it
from the other perspective,
not how would you disarm or someone,
you're just coming at it from how
to you be a person that does live,
you need to be disarmed.
Yeah. Like just, yeah, exactly.
So you're so, so just so,
oh I no, no, you're actually
right. So you're saying if,
if I know you as a guy that doesn't talk
bad and doesn't tell secrets and dozens,
but then I'm going to automatically be
a little bit, you're going to start off,
so you've developed a relationship
with the person with that one.
Really make that your goal.
Cool. Yeah. Good check.
Jocko.
Have you worked with anyone who led
from an emotional or unbalanced place,
but learn to do
tach
and what helped them?
Well, when I was putting
these questions together,
obviously here's one where you also have
to use a little disarmed movement to
get someone that's getting
emotional about something.
You've got to get him to calm down you
so you don't reciprocate the emotion.
Don't coach people when they're angry or
emotional. That's not the time to say,
hey, you know what you need to do
right now is you need to calm down.
It doesn't work out.
You know that that does does work.
Actually Lafe was telling that story
on the last podcast where he was,
he was losing his temper about something.
And I just stood there and said,
kind of smiled and said,
I didn't,
I didn't reciprocate the anger. I
said, hey, take it easy. You know,
don't worry about it. Let's just think
about it. Can you make this happen?
And he's like, yeah, I can. Of
course. I actually, I had a, uh,
one of my,
one of my senior enlisted advisors,
actually my first
deployment to Iraq. And, uh,
and he and I were old school
team one guys. And uh,
well one of my, one of my favorite
guys in the world actually,
but he would sometimes get a little
bit, move snow little bit, little bit.
And he had this tactic that
I picked up from him that I,
that I understood the way he,
the way he addressed conflict was,
and I broke it down for them eventually
was simplify, amplify, and repeat.
That's what he would do.
And it actually worked or worked
a lot of time on most people.
And so like first if I said, hey, uh,
I'm going to need yet, I want to take
a couple more guys on this operation.
And if he didn't think I needed more
guys for an operation, he'd say, well,
why don't you just take everyone in
the compound? I'll tell you what,
just take every person on the roster,
we'll give you little back if
that'll give you enough people.
Then we'll take everyone. I'll, I'll,
I'll start rounding everyone up right now.
We'll take every single
person that we have out there,
and I'll even grab some army guys on the
web. That was his way. And, and, and,
and I'd be like, no man. I know.
What I wouldn't do is I wouldn't get
defensive. I wouldn't get fired up.
And I would say, Hey, no, I'm
not saying I need everybody.
I'm just saying I want to
take a three more guys.
There's some spaces in the vehicles
that'll give us a little more ability to
contain the target in. We'd
look at that. I'd say, look,
take a look at the map we can.
And so then he'd keep calm down.
And in this guy's case,
he actually wasn't like too emotional.
He was just super passionate. And when
I actually broke down the simplify,
amplify and intensify,
oh no. It was simplify,
amplify and repeat. That's what you
do to simplify, amplify, and repeat.
When and then when,
whenever we would start getting into
discussion and he would start doing it,
we would start laughing because he
realized that that's exactly what he was
doing with simplify,
amplify, repeat. That's,
that's what the name you put on
his little theology. Yeah. No.
If you said, like I said, if I said,
hey, I need a couple more guys who take,
we'll just take everyone then if that's
what you need, you need every single guy.
He would simplify what you said. He would
amplify it and make it more extreme.
And he would just repeat
it over and over again.
And most people that he did it too,
they would feel stupid because of what he
did to him. You know, he'd say, well, no,
I don't need, and I'm not even
just feel stupid. And he'd say,
so just ridiculous and,
and he'd win.
But, uh, we had, uh, we, we
would laugh about it, but,
but like I said, he wasn't
actually too emotional. Um,
he was just fired up about stuff,
which is a positive thing,
but someone that is actually
too emotional. So like I
said, you gotta stay calm.
You don't don't coach people when
they're angry, you set a good example.
And then when people come down later,
you talk to them about like gay man,
that wasn't cool and you got to get a
spin it right. Cause you're trying to get,
you're trying to, you don't want to like
literally coach. Cause if I say Echo,
I need to coach you on something,
then you're defensive and all that.
But if I say, hey man, I, oh man,
I rely on you because of your expertise.
And I think you're the only guy in the
platoon that can actually make this
happen. So if you're losing
your temper, man, that doesn't,
all of a sudden I can't count on you and
I need you cause you don't make good.
We, none of us make good decisions if
we're all bent out of shape on something.
So I got out of please can you just,
can you help me by just, hey man,
if you start, if you start
getting angry about something,
just realize it's gonna Affect
your decision making and we can't
have that man. We need to come. We
need to make the good assistance.
People are counting on us and that's
how I'm handling some of that gets
emotional about stuff.
Yeah. That what it simplify.
Repeat one breath, amplify.
And Republicans say,
all girls do this,
but some wives might be,
like you said,
the wives with the last name Charles.
You know, ultimately I think if
you're, if you're in a good relation,
you don't really take it that seriously.
But yeah. You say like, I dunno, you know,
hey you, you were, you said
something mean to me or whatever,
and they'll be little then why'd
you marry me? Then why don't,
why don't you just take it to the, to
that next level. If I amplify and repeat,
yeah. Or, or, or hey, go to this one time,
long time ago, we first got together.
She was, uh, she said she wanted me to
get orange juice. I went to the store,
it's going to store wanting me to
get orange juice for whatever reason.
I forgot the orange juice. I didn't choose
not to get the orange juice. I forgot.
I just forgot. You know, you come
home, forget the orange juice.
She said something along the lines of
does anything I say have any importance to
you at all? That's, that's what that is.
All she needed to do is say it more than
once. And you've got the repeat as well.
Yeah. So I mean, I get stands
to that question. No. Yeah.
Most things are pretty important.
I mean,
maybe not the orange juice at
that moment, you know, I forgot.
Um, the, another tactic,
like when you talk to people,
like they're calm him down or whatever,
like let's say something,
they lose their temper all the
time or something like that.
And you have to dress like them
losing their temper and be like, hey,
you know how, how you used the word
passionate, passionate. It is, is,
it's basically like an excuse word
for someone being like, you know,
when people are just passionate,
I'm passionate. You can
be, it can be a euphemism.
Well,
here's the thing,
being passionate and being emotional is
are two different things because you can
be passionate about something
and not lose your temper.
Not being in whether they're two
different things. So people will be like,
they'll put that on and so it sounds
kind of acceptable. It's simply not true.
But so if, if the, but you can use that
to your advantage. You can be like, Hey,
I know you're passionate. I dig it, man.
It's one of the things I like about you.
And another thing that I like about
you is that you're also a thinker.
That's why boom. And you say
what to do. That's what you do.
The Ninja mind there is,
that's what I like about you or
what I like about you is this,
and then they kind of take on
that role for sure. Yeah. Yeah.
Very good. Very good. Next question,
Dakota.
What do you think of the saying
you get more bees with honey?
They actually asked Leif this too,
but he's not here.
You get more bees with honey.
I was,
I was actually heard you catch more flies
with honey than with vinegar,
but the same idea. And it,
it's something I I agree with.
I mean obviously this is,
comes down to the r word relationships.
And always what I'm trying to do is
I'm trying to build the relationships.
So I'm going to put out the honey, you
know, I'm going to put up the hunting.
The carrot is,
is preferable to the stick,
which is another way of saying it. The
reward, the good stuff, the isn't so,
so yeah, totally that, that absolutely
works better. Um, now you can
give people too much honey and
now they get type two diabetes.
They get lazy,
they get out of shape and they don't
work anymore. Right? So you can't,
you got to do, that's, that's the,
that's the dichotomy that you need to
balance as leader. Not being too hard,
but not being too soft, not being too
aggressive, but being aggressive enough.
That's the dichotomy. But the, the bottom
line is you need to treat people well.
That's what you need to do.
You need to not spoil them,
but give them respect.
And build the relationships.
And if you make that your goal,
when I work with all these different
companies, you know I'm, I'm,
I want to say listen,
make your goal with this person
that you're having a problem with.
Make your goal to build a
relationship that make that your goal.
When they say something negative,
say something positive.
When they want to blame something on you
say, yeah, you're right, it's my fault.
Build a relationship with the person
that's going to strengthen the team is
going to be thousand times infinitely
better than having an antagonistic
relationship with somebody.
Yup.
So I agree with it. And also, you
know when you're leading with vinegar,
when you're leading with
fear and you're leading your,
you're beating people with a stick that
does not work out good in the long run.
Do you have to have
consequences sometimes. Yeah.
But the team that is following somebody
cause they want to do their best for
that leader is going to beat the team
that is doing things only because they're
scared of the road.
Right?
Yeah.
They,
if they're trying to avoid the stick
that's going to be where they operate in
you, they're going to operate
enough to avoid the stigs act.
Cause really that's the goal. To
avoid the stick. There's no honey.
You're not going to go above and beyond.
Yeah.
I think you said something very wise
in a office space. What does he say?
And he said he was in his little review,
he got hypnotized.
Did you watch office space?
I've watched it a million times,
so he gets hypnotized. Alright. So now
he tells me the truth or he doesn't care,
you know about things. So he's
like, he's real open and honest.
He goes into his little review, which is
supposed to be this kind of tense thing.
And they say, I'm like, what's
up? You know, some thought on,
they asked him some stuff and he's like,
it's a cool,
it's a problem of motivation. Like,
you know, we're now if I get, you know,
all the scenes. So he's explained it to
him and then he's like, okay, if I'm,
if I'm scared of, you know,
whatever, this punishment
from my boss or whatever.
No, I'm just going to work
hard enough not to get fired.
But that's true. That's
absolutely true. So yeah,
like these kids who only get scolded,
you know,
they don't get like compassionate and
compliment in support and you know,
that only get scolded a lot of times.
I mean there's a lot more to it,
but a lot of times they're just going
to do the minimum and clearly you're not
get scolded too far. The other direction
where you get spoiled, spoiled. Yup.
You're too far in the other. Yep.
And the dangerous part about getting,
giving to like going too
far in the other direction,
how you put it is you don't
prepare them like they,
they wind up when they're on their own.
Like they're not prepared for the
tough part. Yeah. The, the, yeah.
And there's a lot of good parts in
life, man. But those tough parts,
they're there too. So if you're not
prepared from, you're going to get jacked,
for lack of a better term. That's
the correct term. Actually,
that last question,
juggle great topic for me would be
staying committed to life change.
I start strong and fade fast
into old habits. Please help.
I'm going to,
yeah,
I'm going to have to bring in the
little Shakespeare on this one.
Shakespeare between the acting of a
dreadful thing and the first motion,
all the interim is like a
fantasma or a hideous dream
and that's Brutus
from Julius Caesar and Brutus in
the play is plotting to kill Caesar.
Someone he was loyal to.
In Shakespeare,
the Master of understanding human
nature captures what that feels like.
And here's what these lines mean
between the acting of a dreadful thing.
So that's the moment,
that moment when you're waiting to do
something that you don't want to do
and the first motion.
So that's when you actually start doing
that thing that you don't want to do
all the interim.
Now this is all that time,
all that time in that moment while
you are waiting to take action.
Okay.
Is like a fantasma or a hideous dream.
Yeah.
So that moment, that moment when
you're waiting to do something,
it's like an apparition, a
hideous dream, a nightmare.
Cancel the battle,
the struggle
it takes place in that moment.
It's not knowing what to do.
That's not the battle.
It's not actually doing it.
It's the moment in between.
It's the hesitation.
Hesitation is the enemy
and in war,
understanding where the enemy
is allows you to defeat him
and this is where the enemy of action,
the enemy of commitment,
the enemy of change,
that's where the enemy lies.
It lies in the waiting
in.
All you have to do to win
is overcome that moment.
The waiting,
the hesitation.
Yeah.
All you have to do is go,
move,
take action, get out of bed,
get your feet on the ground,
step into the gym, put down the
doughnut, pick up the kettle bell.
Do not hesitate. Do not wait, go forward,
go to war
and when
every single time,
and I think that's
all I've got for tonight.
Thanks to everybody out there
for listening and for all the
awesome continued support or get getting
from everybody if you want to keep
supporting echo.
How'd they do that?
Well,
primarily
I would say support yourself
with supplementation
because really that's really
what it's about.
Not necessarily the supplementation
but supporting yourself as well.
It was kind of like when you, when you,
um, when you fly in the airplane, yeah.
You know,
you've got to put the mask over your
self first before you do you help your
infant. Yeah. Yeah. Cause if you're
not dope, like he, you know, you,
you know what I mean? So
anyway, if you need supplements,
go to [inaudible] dot com slash
Jocko get 10% off on it. Supplements.
What does that mean? That's the
best supplements. I like it.
And you got 10% off. Um, I could
explain why they're so good,
but you can go on the website,
read it. Just trust me.
It's the only supplements I take
in you too, right? Yes, indeed.
Where you take something else, cleans,
don't vitamin, something like that.
Or you can support by clicking
through before you do Amazon shopping.
Click through the website
or just get the trooper to,
I think that'd be a lot easier.
So you go to the website,
get the troop tool called Jocko
podcast, trooper tool, chrome extension.
Click on it. Boom. Confirm. Boom. It's
on there. Anytime you shop at Amazon,
you support passively this podcast
and you're kind of official.
That's dope.
I don't like the word passive even though
I know it's the correct term because
when you are shop, that's
a, that's a really good,
easy way to support the podcast.
So I don't agree with you on the passage.
I like passive and
they're actively shopping,
actively getting after
it passively supporting.
They actively went to the website,
they actively installed the
tool or they click through,
they're taking action and they're
making things happen. Yup.
And if the credit and it's efficient
to give him credit and official anyway,
nonetheless, that's a way.
And um, that's a good way.
A subscribe on iTunes. Of course, if
you haven't already write a review.
Yeah.
To write a review.
Somebody wrote an awesome review
the other day that's appreciate it.
Cause then we know what we're doing here.
We're getting a feedback.
I'm reading the reviews. Yeah.
And it goes reading the reviews.
Subscribe to Youtube and
we're going to be more,
little bit more active on the youtube.
So it won't be just ideal version.
I'm going to get act. I'm going to do it.
Why don't you get a lot more? Actually,
I'm doing it. I'm active. I'm more
active. That's good. That's it right now.
So that's again, subscribe to
Youtube now. Lens, how about this?
Subscribe to Youtube.
If I'm putting out dumb stuff,
if a mucking it up.
But right now it's just, you
know, the video version of
the podcast, which is cool.
If you'd like podcasts, why not like to
be doing version? If you even like videos,
I'm going to add some stuff in there,
some whatever.
Some I'll take the deleted scenes, other
stuff, little mash ups or whatever.
If they're lame,
just unsubscribe.
You're confident that they will
not be there. I'm confident yet,
but I actually thought the first
one was uh, it was pretty dark.
Yeah, yeah, yeah. But you know
what's funny about those things?
It's a big inside joke for somebody
that's like no one is that doesn't,
if someone stumbles across
that video and watches it,
you're going to mean nothing to yeah.
To get,
they'll get anybody that is in the
game with us. Yeah, they're there.
They know what's funny.
Yeah. They call those Easter,
like those little Easter eggs in there.
Like you know the trooper tool video.
There's little Easter eggs in there,
you know,
if you play it back and pay attention
to whatever. Yeah, I like that.
Just like the shirts as cautionary tales.
Sharp man.
Everybody saw that on your Amazon page
that you displayed? Yeah, the duck tape.
Actually if you look closer it's
like, well yeah, this, this stuff is,
he strikes in everything.
You just want to give them away.
That's part of the fun part of it
nonetheless. Yeah, sure. Youtube,
you can support that way.
And of course if you like the shirts,
get a shirt, got a kind of a new
one that the trooper one. It just,
it's just the basic brand in Jocko
podcast. If you're on youtube right now,
I'm wearing one right now.
Debbie one over the,
one of the troopers.
She took a picture of the day like wow.
Just amazing background.
Mountains, Snow Cap, mountains,
trees,
trooper trooper Tisher.
Outstanding. That was good.
Yeah. Well they are good.
I didn't make it a point to get the
good ones. They're not like, you know,
you know, the process of creating quality
quality yet I didn't just be like,
hey, give me the cheapest possible
one. The ballpark giveaway.
I didn't do that. I was to get the,
you know, I went through some lengths.
So they're so they're good.
Wearable. My goal is to be like,
if you put it on you'd be like, this
is my, regardless of what's on it,
this is my favorite shirt.
That's the goal.
And so the design is just a bonus.
I like to think so. Yeah, that's,
that's a great bonus. But yeah,
you get a shirt Jocko, store.com boom,
get us, you get a sticker too if you want.
There's a few options there and a coffee
mug and may or may not have some Jocko
White Tea,
pomegranate.
Maybe we haven't got a little something
coming out. You're working with the,
working with a company.
A lot of people would talk to me
about the beverage that I drink. Yeah.
I drink some Alpha brain,
but my most common beverage is the Palmer.
Yup. And that didn't find that
out on Tim Ferriss. Right.
He first people went crazy. Yeah. Cause
he was asking, Hey, what does that,
what does that, what does he drink?
Kind of seeing him when he drank it,
he got all fired up. Listen to them,
listen to Tim Ferriss podcast. He's at,
this is like an adrenaline fueled. There's
caffeine in though. And yeah, there's,
there's a small amount of caffeine,
well I shouldn't say small, usually.
Usually white tees about a
third of a cup of coffee.
So it's pretty mild on the caffeine
and he's like a micro dose of caffeine,
just may antioxidants in
there and it tastes good.
And so anyways, it got
approached about, hey, we are,
we're fans of the Jocko podcast
and guess what? We make tea, boom,
we want to make your tea.
So I went through some iterations trying
to find it and tune it, the little,
the mixture.
And now we got to listen.
Talk away to the Brown's. It's
going to be good. Yeah. Uh, so what,
we'll put it on the Jocko store,
some kind of connection to get it,
you know what Matt and I don't know
when that'll be out there sometime soon.
Yeah.
And you put that thing on there where
people can have get emails from us.
Yeah. Oh yes. I the the mailing list,
right. Put simply as a mailing list.
It's the, it's more for like, like
insiders if you care about like,
I dunno, insight or stuff. So I don't,
you know how like there's a lot of mailing
lists or whatever you can get on and
they'll like send you a mass email every,
make it a point not to say new stuff
that's like not relevant because you
sometimes know sign up
for that before. Yeah. No,
don't fill people's email box
with stuff that is just stuff.
It's like, it's like, hey, here's
my email. Violate my trust. No Man,
no, I'll send you me. Yeah, I'll, I'll,
when I, if there's something comes up.
Yeah. And not the kind of like,
Hey, one out of all these people,
one of these people might be interested
in this. Let me send it to everybody.
It's not that kind. No. If I think
everyone's gonna be interested,
I could be wrong. But if I think that
genuinely, and I'll send you some tanned.
Furthermore,
if there is a pandemic epic,
a disaster situation,
I will be sending forth instructions
for all the troopers to congregate and
dominate. And that's what we're going to
do. Katie event as a Zombie apocalypse.
See that alone right there.
Is there either and at some point do you
know at some point I may send out like
a longer thing like for
instance upcoming right?
We got the monster right?
Lafe and I are doing here in San Diego.
Got To get out some details on that
so people know when it's going down,
all that stuff.
I'm gonna send that out through there
so that people know what's happening.
They get connected. So that's,
that's an example. Yeah.
Am I going to email it 47
times? No. Hey reminder.
But I know if you're enlisted on the,
on the mail, then you're interested
in what we're saying. Yeah.
So I think this is what we're
putting it out there. We are.
We're not going to violate that.
Here's my email. Violate my trust.
You know how they'll, cause they'll send
you stuff every like three days. Oh yeah.
If you let them sometimes multiple
times a day. Oh, who does that?
Why would you, why is that? I'm not
going to name the marketing on it. No.
Is that considered to be good marketing?
Somebody wants to be telling people to
do that. I don't know. You know what?
That's,
that's,
that's what I don't want
to do these market things.
Yeah. See that's the thing. If anybody
out there thinks a marketing things,
stop me. Do it. Well I did recently.
There's a difference between
advertising and marketing.
So marketing is everything. Like
if, if even you wearing that shirt,
that's technical marketing
for Victor Advertising. Okay,
well on the other hand busted. I don't
want to get into a big thing here bro.
I was talking to him then we market
and we advertise for no, we mark it.
We don't ever advertise.
We don't know. Okay.
And what about when I say, what about
when you say hey on it has good stuff.
And I say, yeah, get the Krill oil that's
on it. Advertising technically. Okay,
I'm, I'm, we're in the advertising. Well,
what I don't want to do is beat people
down with, you know, buy this, buy that.
I don't want to do that on it is actually
supporting the podcast and I support
on it.
That's Joe Rogan's company and Joe
Rogan is a great guy who helped us out,
who walked by the way, we're sitting here
because of Joe Rogan, Fyi. All right,
the other way, I also, you got the, um,
you can buy a little book called extreme
ownership written by myself and my
brother Leif Babin who was on
the last podcast podcast 34,
he was also on podcast
11 and we wrote a book.
It's about leadership, it's about war,
it's about business, it's about life.
And it's available in hardcover
and digital audio format.
Both Lafe and I reread the sections
that we wrote. So that's cool.
And you know, what's cool is get it for
yourself, which is cool. It'll help you.
But then he'll per team grabbed
him a copy and you're helping us,
you know a little bit. Yeah, it's for
support. Go think good about that book.
I said this before,
but it's worth saying again is that,
you know how like some books it's like,
okay,
I'm going to improve in in whatever.
I'm going to read this book.
It's just helped me in this
way or that way or whatever.
But this is like the kind of stuff
where you can literally turn on that.
Like right when you read a certain
sentence and it's giving you whatever,
you know, whatever this
advice is, whichever one it
is, but extreme ownership,
we'll say you can turn it
on right then in there,
like right then and there you can walk
with you and you have to read the whole
book technically and it'll,
you'll already be changed.
That's awesome.
You just got to do it.
I'm saying like not all books are
like that. It's like, oh yeah,
it's this gradual process that
is awesome. But anyway, that's,
that's a big takeaway I got from it.
Now as always,
if you want to let us know
what's going on in your world,
you want to continue this little
talk that we're having amongst us.
We're all up in the inner
webs, Twitter, Facebook,
and Instagram. Echo is at Echo,
Charles and I am at jockowillink.
Now, one of the things that I've made
a note here to talk about little bit.
Got To, got to come clean
here, got to address something.
Uh,
went on a little trip into the bush,
was out of contact before
I left on the trip.
Aye
Stopped. I didn't stop, but
I could no longer keep up,
could no longer keep up with responding.
There was a time they're all up until
a week ago,
maybe,
maybe a week and a half ago.
I committed and responded to every single
person that hit me on
Twitter a hundred percent.
And I kept trying to maintain and I told
everyone I'm gonna maintain and I'd,
and I maintained for a long time
for what, six months, seven months,
something like that. But I,
I cannot maintain anymore.
I cannot respond to every single person.
Um,
and especially coming back from
being in the field for, you know,
seven days where I didn't have
it or have it very sparingly.
I'm getting thousands of tweets a day,
which is awesome. And you know what?
I do read them all.
I absolutely read them all,
but to respond to every single one
of them, I don't, I don't have time.
Starting about a week and a half ago,
I just said, Nah, I can't do this.
Because first of all we went
to the whole thing of like, oh,
we're going to go two times a week
for the podcast. The one time,
two times a month for the podcast,
maybe one every two weeks.
Most people didn't like that.
I didn't like that.
I want to come in here and
get it on. So, but well and,
and I used to be able to respond to
the Twitter in like 45 minutes a day,
which I find that time I'll make
that time. Then it was an hour,
then it was an hour and 10 minutes and
all of a sudden it became two hours a day.
And then if think about this,
if I missed a day for whatever reason
or missed a day and a half, five hours.
Finally one Sunday I sat down and I did
Twitter for a stupid amount of time,
you know, six something hours and
Twitter's a great method of communication,
but
I got to
be more selective and disciplined
about my time management.
I don't want to carry
this on even further, but
the reason I'm kind of like
kind of laughing is that,
cause you're kind of new
to social media kind of.
But it's funny cause like you're saying,
this is going to sound strange,
but you're that nice of a person that
you're like telling everyone like we know,
we know you can respond to, but you're
like really bothered by it. You're like,
God I can't, I'm not a prude. I being
rude. That's what's fun. I feel bad.
It's funny because from
your perspective it's like,
it's like someone's talking to you for
real and you're just like basically
putting your finger up saying I don't,
you know, I don't have time for you,
you know, but anything in your arm,
we are kind of a group, a team,
which makes it even more,
which I'm sort of like the guy that
facilitates the communication between us
from an almost a leadership position.
And so for now, and you know,
it was funny because uh,
one of,
one of the troopers guy named Brandon
who's been in the game since day one,
I forget how he found,
I think,
I think he listened to Tim Ferriss bark
and he immediately like followed me on
Twitter and we were going back
and forth on a bunch of stuff and,
and finally we were emailing about some
stuff we were emailing about. Uh, he,
he was trying
to get Timex to sponsor the
podcast or me or something.
Cause Timex is selling watches factually,
factually the, a lot of people
have bought Timex ironman watches,
watches from your thing, just from
phone, from wanting to get in the game.
You know, like, oh yeah, that's cool
man, let's do it. It's good. You know.
And so a lot of people have
factually bought those watches.
And so Brandon trooper was
like, Hey, you know what,
I'm going to contact these guys.
So we went back on a bunch of emails.
I have pictures of me with this watch
on with his Timex watch it you see on my
Twitter feed, not the exact
same watch but the same model,
watch the same model.
And I have I think five of them right now.
And actually some troopers
sent me other older,
cause you can't buy them anymore.
So I have,
I have enough of these watches to last
me for the rest of my life. You know,
I think it's about five or six and,
and I've actually done surgery on these
watches over the years. Like yeah,
like one would break a certain part.
So I'd taken other one apart and
I put the insides and you know,
so one day I was reading an email from
Brandon cause we emailed back and forth
on this a couple of times. And then the
other day he emailed me, just said, hey,
just so you know, I haven't given
up, I'm still on time accident.
I sent him an email and I was
reading it on the way here to record.
And uh, and I was, I was looking
through the email when I parked,
I suppose his phone number at the
bottom and I just hit, you know,
it's the iPhone. I hit it, I hit
the thing and it called. And uh,
and I said, and he's like, hey, this is
Brandon. And I said, hey, what's up man?
It's Jocko. And he's like, really?
I go, yeah man, what's going on?
I just wanted to touch base. And
he's, uh, and, and so I said,
so we started talking and this
was right as the social media,
I was reaching the kind of the
end of the line of social media.
And as I'm sort of thinking about how
I'm going to manage and how I'm going to,
like, if I could tell people like,
listen, I'm sorry, I just can't, I can't,
I physically can't do it.
And one of the things he says to
me while we're talking, he goes,
you know what's so awesome is that you
respond to everybody. And I was like,
so I s I stuck with it. I
said, okay, you know what? I'm
behind him. And he sit down.
And I think that's when I
did like a Sunday where I
just sat there like an idiot.
I know, but it just boom, boom,
boom, boom and fingers to zoom.
A lot of people are telling me good
stuff and I'm not going to say, hey man,
thanks. That's a good point. Oh, that's
a good book. I'm gonna check that out.
So when he told me that, I
said, okay, to hold the line,
I got to hold the line and then,
and then I realized if I'm gonna hold
the line on that I'm going to let go of
more important things.
One of them being the podcast,
one of them be in the podcast and
not putting forth quality podcasts,
which to me is the most important thing
that, that I'm doing right now is,
is getting the podcast quality
from a podcast perspective. Right.
Um, so yeah, there's my, there's
my social media adventure.
No.
Yeah.
But it's funny to think of it from
your perspective because I would argue,
I would guess that from everyone else's
respective, it's like, yeah, no kidding.
Kidding. Yeah. Yeah. You're speaking, but
Nah, man. Good on you. Really give them,
yeah, I think that's, that's cool. Wow.
I apologize everybody. But uh, and I'm,
I'm telling him still like reading them,
but it's, I can't respond to
every guy. You're the man.
But what I'm going to try and do is since
I don't have to be sweating the more
responses,
if I tweet,
I'm going to try and like be a little
bit more active as things happen. Cool.
Things happen, whatever. We'll
see how that works out. Uh,
all right,
to close it out.
Thanks
always and once again to the uniform
folks out there, the firefighters,
police and law enforcement and
of course the military members,
thanks to you all for holding the line
and to the other troopers that
are out there that are listening,
who have opened your
ears and open your mind.
You,
you who are looking at yourself every day
day like we do,
thinking,
how can I be better?
Thanks for doing that.
Thanks for making that
daily self assessment.
Thanks for moving forward.
Without hesitation
in most important.
Thanks for getting after it.
So until next time,
this is echo and Jocko
out.